[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is the global
creative platform makes it easy for
designers and clients to work together
from logos to apps business cards
packaging to books you name it 99designs
is the go-to design resource for any
budget right now my listeners that see
you guys can get $50 off a logo and
brand identity package from 99 designs
plus a free upgrade that lets you
promote your project on the platform
which is an additional $99 value by
checking out 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim 50 that's TI m50 so 99
science.com forward slash Tim 50 as many
of you know I've used 99 designs for
many many years now I've used them for
book covers including mock-ups for the
4-hour body which went on to become a
number one New York Times best seller
illustrations for the multi-volume the
Tao of Seneca is an ebook series
basically and other graphic design
projects and I've been very impressed by
the quality of their designers and
illustrators and you can check out all
sorts of stuff like the town of Seneca
to get an idea they're they're really
mind-boggling most recently I used 99
designs to update the illustrations and
layout of my 5 morning rituals eBook
this is a PDF that I offer as an
incentive to get people to sign up for
my newsletter the illustrations inside
are gorgeous and I loved working with
the designer who ended up selecting for
the project you can take a look at that
this is a real world example of the type
of thing that I use 99 designs for at 99
designs Calm forward slash Tim 50 99
designs designer search tool connects
you directly with one designer based on
design category or industry
specialization style skill level
availability and more you just check off
the boxes that you need to satisfy the
criteria you want and it will bring up
the
best matches or you can start a contest
you invite the entire community to take
a shot at your project then you pick
your favorite so to get $50 off your
first logo and brand identity package as
well as additional promotion on the
platform with the free upgrade please
visit 99designs dot-com forward slash
Tim 50 that's 99designs com forward
slash Tim 50 and click on the link on
the landing page check it out 99designs
comm forward slash Tim 50 this episode
is brought to you by Charlotte's Web
which makes a CBD oil a hip extract that
has become one of my go-to tools now I
have never really talked about CBD oil
and cannabis has never really been the
plant for me and over talking about hip
but nonetheless after several nights of
inexplicable insomnia this is about a
year ago I just could not get to sleep
to save my life and after other fixes
failed so melatonin California Poppy
extract da da da da da an elite athlete
introduced me to this non psychoactive
extract and bam problem solved I had
some of the best sleep that I'd had in
months now I don't use sleep aids on a
daily basis but this has become part of
my toolkit and I hope to be exploring
other applications soon CBD oil products
have exploded in popularity in the
health and wellness and fitness worlds
and Charlotte's Web is one of the top
players that offers a broad spectrum
hemp extract with CBD in the form of
oils capsules and topical products
Charlotte's Web products will not get
you high so that may be that is good
news may be bad news to you but it does
have some powerful benefits and
applications and it works with your
body's existing endocannabinoid system
endo meaning from within like endo vs
exoskeleton for instance so
endocannabinoid system works with your
body some of the most common uses are
for relief from everyday stressors help
in supporting restful sleep which is
what I most often use it for to bring
about a sense of calm and focus a lot of
my friends use it for that CBD is also
known or becoming known for helping
athletes to recover from
exercise-induced inflammation
Charlotte's Web hemp X
has naturally-occurring terpenes
flavonoids and other valuable hemp
compounds that work synergistically to
heighten positive effects sometimes
referred to as the entourage effect
which you guys can look up making it
more complete than single compound CBD
alternatives or at least that is what
I've been told I do not know much about
CBD alternatives North single compound
in any case
check it out this stuff has really
worked for me to jump over to CW hemp
dot-com forward slash Tim CW is in
Charlotte's Web CW hemp comm forward
slash Tim to take a quick quiz which
will determine the best product for your
particular Ames lifestyle etc and they
ship to all 50 states Charlotte's Web
are offering listeners of this podcast
10% off of their purchase while there
are some exclusions I personally use the
extra strength CBD oils or the extra
strength capsules and you can see what
might be a fit for you on that page and
there is a 30-day risk free guarantee so
why not try it out
so get 10% off of your purchase at CW
hemp comm forward slash Tim and
disclaimer these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration this product is not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease
enjoy bye hello you sexy little minx
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim bear show or
it is my job to interview and
deconstruct world-class performers
whether they come from the worlds of
chess sports business it really doesn't
matter we're trying to spot patterns of
excellence what are the habits the
routines the favorite books the morning
exercises whatever it might be that you
can test and apply in your own lives and
my guest today is a friend we've been
trying to make the podcast happen for
quite a few years now and he is a
polymath you need to listen to this
episode Nik cojones is his name last
name is spelled ko ko na s NIC CONUS on
instagram @ n cojones on twitter at nick
cojones nick is the co-owner and
co-founder of the Alinea group of rest
which includes Alinea next the aviary
Royster I think I'm getting that right
in the aviary New York City NYC that is
he's also the founder and CEO of Tok Inc
a reservations and CRM system for
restaurants with more than two and a
half million diners and clients in more
than 20 countries now you might be
thinking wait a second restaurants food
that's not my thing doesn't matter we're
gonna get into philosophy we're gonna
get into derivatives trading we're gonna
get into books like fooled by randomness
the problems of philosophy hi
let's see peregrinations of an epicurean
and how Nick seems to break every
industry or type of business he goes
into in the most productive way possible
it's a really fun conversation but back
to the bio Alinea a li and EA which by
the way I based basically an entire
section of the 4-hour chef on which was
one of my books because I was so
impressed Alinea has been named the best
restaurant in America and best
restaurant in the world by organizations
and lists as diverse as the James Beard
Foundation they give James Beard Awards
out which kind of like the Oscars in the
food world world's 50 best TripAdvisor
yelp Gourmet magazine and elite traveler
his restaurants have won nearly every
accolade afforded them despite the fact
that he does not or didn't at least have
any experience whatsoever in restaurants
and he had some amazing amazing partners
we get into but that set of beginners
eyes is really really crucial and we dig
into how he cultivates that a lot nick
has been he uses this word a subversive
entrepreneur which I agree with and
angel investor since 1996 he spent a
decade as a very successful derivatives
trader has co-written three books and
believes in radical transparency in
markets and business his latest effort
is the aviary cocktail book which is
perhaps the most gorgeous book I've ever
seen I got an early copy it is stunning
it is just unbelievable what they've
done it is self-published has already
sold that is pre-sold nearly million
dollars in copies and is being released
right now shipped right now in
of 2018 it is truly I think the most
beautiful book I have ever seen and held
in my hands so you can find out all
about it you can see all sorts of photos
and samples at the aviary book calm
that's dub dub dub dot the aviary
book.com
avi ary check it out so I'll leave it at
that
please listen to this episode even if
you have no interest in food it doesn't
matter we span so many different
businesses industries life lessons I had
a blast with this and I hope you do as
well here to Nick cook Onis Nick welcome
to the show
thanks Tim awesome to be here finally
yeah yeah we have the benefit of having
spent some time together and I have been
fed a lot of caffeine by you and you're
also a great help with the 4-hour chef
so I wanted to right off the bat thank
you for that it was a lovely experience
it was kind of a fun thing because I
remember when you you sent me up to
preview the book and then you called me
to say like hey you know do you want to
say anything about it and I was like on
a chairlift and I was like by the time I
get off this chairlift I will have a
blurb for you with such pressure well
which which meant a lot and pressure I
think is the word to describe I so much
about you and your life I want to say
trajectory but I'm not even sure that is
the right word and I thought a fun way
to kick off the conversation would be to
share with people listening some of the
back and forth that we had when we were
brainstorming what a podcast might look
like because certainly I I don't think
of you first and foremost as a food guy
per se and we were we were having this
exchange via text and then via email and
I thought I'd just read one of your
responses as we were swapping different
ideas and I probably edit for space a
little bit here
but not by much and here we go I'm a
huge believer in radical transparency in
business I give numbers and burn bridges
with big companies because I think that
a lot of times people don't ask the
basic questions in publishing for
instance how much did that book cost
print how many did it sell oddly those
numbers are very hard to come by I dug
from months years ago to do the Alinea
book the right way for bars
why does a bartender wash dishes and
talk to customers we've redesigned the
bar experience and won best bar in the
world for restaurants why is it the only
form of entertainment
that has only a mutual promise to show
up and then it goes into behavioral
economics and in parentheses I don't
even know how to pronounce this last
name correctly Richard Thaler or is it
ale yeah as a friend and investor just
won the Nobel Prize
investing been beating the market for
nearly 30 years everything in all caps
is about asymmetric risk-taking and
information and yet people people's
perception of risk or of what I do is
that it's risky it is not and in a
separate exchange when we were talking
about many of the topics that you could
talk about outside of say restaurants
bars and so on even though that's been a
big part of your life in recent history
many of these different experiments
explorations portions of your career
topics that you could talk about and
then going into what you said they come
down to a single thought really wherever
there is opaque information that should
be obvious run to that gap so I struggle
with where to even begin with the 20 of
the 20 options that we have here but
maybe maybe you could maybe you could
explain to me how behavioral economics
and Richard Thaler fit into this just
just for a for curiosity's sake yeah I
mean well I'll go back to the word you
used options because I started out back
in nineteen ninety two or three studying
options trading derivatives trading and
I think there's a huge misconception
about what that is because of movies
because of the big short because of you
know Wall Street all that it's a bit
like playing a game of chess for
or being the house at a casino that sort
of thing it's about taking you know
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
decisions per day and pretending it's
like a big decision tree and any given
decision is probably got you know if
you're really good forty-eight percent
chance of being wrong so you have to be
you have to be really really good at
constantly being comfortable being wrong
but knowing that your overall number of
of decisions that you're gonna be right
more than you're wrong and so like I
know there's like a big theme a lot of
the folks that you have on like they
talked about success or failure or how
to measure those things and I kind of
don't look at it a success or failure
with anything I look at it as just like
is my pattern of decisions correct and
then getting back to your actual
question with professor Thaler and
behavioral economics and I mean
essentially what they're looking at is
is decision making what drives people to
make certain decisions what's rational
about those decisions
what is mostly irrational or emotional
or what decisions do we make that people
don't even realize they're they're
making a decision which is often the
case as well and then if you think about
it every single form of what we do art
Commerce science you know picking a mate
like all those things comes down to a
whole bunch of decisions that you make
without often really thinking about the
decision itself not that you can go
around walking around going well I've
just made another decision but when you
are doing you know business or or
starting a company or publishing a book
or whatever it may be you can be
intentional about that and realize that
it's going to be an iterative process
and so I think that's that's been not
only the case for me in learning how to
filter things through that mindset but
like when you said there isn't really a
trajectory like I kind of look at
everything I've done is the same in a
way even though other people look at it
and go like wow you went from being a
derivatives trader to owning restaurants
like that's weird and I studied
philosophy in college so like people are
like how do you go from philosophy to
finance
you know and to me it was all the same
thing how was that that particular
transition or rather progression I
suppose from philosophy to finance is
one that you and I haven't really talked
about and that that one is interesting
too I'd love to explore for a second and
we're going to go into a million
different nooks and crannies yeah yeah
yeah but it was do you feel like
philosophy was studying philosophy
undergrad was an asset that then later
helped you or was it just an interest
you explored on route to other things no
I I can't
remotely imagine having not not done
that and the way that actually I did it
was really interesting I had no
intention of when I got to college I
thought I'd studied political science
economics pre-law kind of thing
something like that and my very like
second week at Colgate University
wonderful professor who just passed away
last year at 94 years old really great
mentor to me professor Jerome Bal math
was a tenured professor at Colgate for
almost 60 years pulled me aside
introduction to logic you know 101 and
basically said what do you what are you
studying here and I told them and he
said no you're gonna be a philosophy
major I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna teach
you how to think and and he was the kind
of guy like there's like there's this
great scene in a river runs through it
where the were the dad you know every
time the kid writes an essay like the
young you know fisherman kid writes an
essay and he brings it to his father to
be graded he gives it back to him says
half as long again and that's like long
before that movie ever came out
professor Bell mouth would would
essentially assign a paper to the class
and say it should be about 15 pages and
people would be like well how long and
he'd always say like you know how long
is a piece of string like it's however
long it needs to be and then he would
tell me yours can't be longer than three
pages and and people would be like
jealous like wow you only have to write
three pages if you take it seriously
that is a much much harder thing to do
so he really trained me as well as a
number of other professors there to be
clear and thinking succinct to you know
understand what logic was to process
information
and really to look for parallels in
different fields and different fields of
thought and so man like when I got out
of school I went to law school for like
a day and a half that means a pet I got
into pen like a joint JD ph.d program at
Penn and as soon as I kind of knew the
other folks were and what their their
desires and trajectories were I was like
oh this isn't actually a good fit for me
and I remember my future father-in-law
told my now wife then girlfriend that I
was in danger of becoming an
intellectual bum because I dropped out
of I dropped out of law school before I
really entered law school and you know I
floundered around for a little while but
you know if you grew up in Chicago you
end up meeting people who who had this
unusual lifestyle and that was back in
the day is pre pre-internet pre pre
electronic trading Mountain pretty high
frequency trading where there was
literally people on a giant trading
floor that shouting at each other and
you either were attracted to the I don't
know almost animalistic nature of that
and for me it was like a huge challenge
because there are people down there that
were had you know phd's from MIT and
then there was people who were like you
know butchers that went down there with
$100,000 and just kicked ass and and and
so it was it wasn't about your your
level of education or any of the stuff I
already talked about it was about can
you show up every day and every day's
game day and be really disciplined and
very clear-headed in in with KS around
to you and you get introduced to that
world you know if you grew up in Chicago
you know some of these guys and some of
them are flashy and I can remember the
exact moment I'm not gonna name a name
here as you'll find out why in a second
but I was walking down the street I was
like you know six months out of college
kind of didn't know what I was going to
do and I was walking down the street and
I bumped into a guy I knew in high
school and you know he wasn't the best
student he didn't try the hardest and I
was like hey what are you doing now and
he was like well I'm just rehabbing
these homes and I thought literally like
oh he's a construction worker and
I was like you know what are you doing
with him he's like well I just bought
this block I'm turning this all over
this is the true story this is so not
like you know a good reason to do
something but but I looked at him and I
was like what are you talking about he's
like yeah I skipped college and I
started out as a runner on the floor of
the Merc and now I you know I own like
25 condos and three townhomes and and I
trade and I kind of went like wow you
know I don't know what I knew a little
bit about it I'd been down on the floor
before just visiting but I was kind of
like that's fascinating like that is a
truly fascinating thing and you know I
went down visited the floor I had to
fake my resume in the wrong direction to
get a job true story like people lie on
their resume all the time I'm probably
the only person that got rid of like you
know my degree and my my like academic
awards and all that because you know to
get a clerk job on the floor the last
thing they wanted was someone with a
good degree Phi Beta Kappa
you know magna laude all that stuff
so I faked my resume got a $5 an hour
job and looked for a mentor and I found
a guy named Frank Cerino who was at
Chicago research and trading who was
which also was founded by a philosophy
major it's actually very common and why
is that common I I don't I wish I knew
the answer I I don't know the answer i I
do know that there's three or four the
largest trading firms in the world run
by philosophy majors and if you look
back at my my class just of you know
there's a few professors in there but
there are people who make movies there's
a guy who runs an ad agency a large ad
agency like it was it's a really
interesting path it's not just like
studying physics you know like I know
some great physicists who who are great
in whatever they do and I think it's I
think it's a similar discipline of
abstract thought mm-hmm like I can't
think of anything worse than studying
business okay it just seems like a
terrible thing to study to me is that is
that because it's like the surface of
the waves in the ocean
topically it's just so non-transferable
in a sense and then as you go lower and
lower to the slower moving layers that's
just more multidisciplinary in terms of
studying like the basics of how things
work or how people think yeah I think
it's it's almost like it's how to do
something or how to manage something but
not why to do it right and and so if if
you're taught in 1992 if I went got an
MBA I would have been taught a certain
kind of management that six years later
with the internet would have gotten
blown up and so for me it's like I
always ask the why question you know
when we're you know you were mentioning
like the book publishing or a bar like
you know I just looked at some things
and it's like why is that okay why does
it work that way and oftentimes the
people most entrenched in a system have
no idea why they're like the third or
fourth generation of person within that
system and they have no idea why school
bell rings in the morning for example or
why a bartender is washing the dishes
and often I don't know the real answer
but I come up with alternative ones at
least that's you can find narrative I
guess undervalued skill by the way in
some cases right you got to be careful
but very very very very very very
interesting I want to pause here
partially because I'm over caffeinated I
wasn't inspired by my nostalgia related
to your the double espressos up but why
did the professor pull you aside what
did that early undergrad professor in
logic 101 see in you whether he
explained it or not later
I don't know that led him to take a
special interest in you well I you know
I think I think I was prepared in
earnest because I was mostly terrified
you know he had a reputation of being
kind of like a you know he was a
Socratic method teacher he was pretty
harsh
Colgate was very small classes and there
was a class of you know
any people and he kind of wanted to
whittle it down to a more manageable
number and his method to do that was
just to kick your ass
remember I mean he probably as great as
he was he I doubt he would survive
starting out at a college campus now
I mean I've literally I literally saw
him like fired - someone's notebook once
when he was asking people like examples
of how to put out a fire and this one
guy was just stuttering because he was
so in fear and so he just lives notebook
on fire and stamped and the kid threw it
on the ground stamped on he's like you
could smother it sure
and he called everyone he memorized
every person's last name and it was mr.
and Miz and I remember the specific day
he was literally at you know back to the
it was like right out of a movie he is
back to the class writing on a
chalkboard you know some some logic
problems symbolic logic and the guy next
to me had no shot at getting it done
right and so he said his name and and I
wrote on the paper on my desk so he
could see it like what what the answer
was and then without missing a beat or
turning around he was like mr. cowness
please do not help him there is no way
in hell he could possibly have done that
without your help and and this is like
two or three weeks in right and he spun
around and he saw that I didn't have my
book and he said mr. kotis where is your
book and I say it's at my it's in my
dorm room you know professor and he said
well a lot of good it's doing you there
I said on the contrary it must
apparently be doing me a lot of good
there and he said I'll see you after
class so I thought I was getting kicked
out and there's a line for me to create
office hours or to like ask to be
transferred out or whatever and when I
got to the front he said follow me and I
fought him to his office and I swear I
mean he's you know running through the
fall New England fall and and I thought
I was gonna get kicked out of the class
and when I closed the door I turned
around he has for you up on the desk and
he said where are you from what do you
want to do here and that was it like he
took me under his wing I was and you
know it's like I never knew here's the
amazing part I never knew the guy liked
me until 10 years after I graduated
and then I was treated like a member of
his family at his funeral 30 years later
huh right so really fascinating person
really fascinating you know moment in my
life where I don't know someone saw
something in me and kind of went like
I'm gonna make an investment in this
person they never asked for anything
back you know ever how did you not know
that he liked you did he withhold in
some way so that you wouldn't get a big
head or something along those lines did
he not want to get it too overly
attached to you so he wouldn't know I I
think I was 19 years old and I didn't
know that the people you liked you hold
to a higher standard probably right and
so consequently you know I like it was
really like he beat the out of me
in a good way like he it's like if you
have someone who's teaching you
something and they invest their time in
you and they think you have a chance of
being good they work you harder than the
folks around you so the people that I
thought he liked he was just being nice
too because they didn't he didn't think
they had a chance right yeah yeah he
didn't care he wasn't invested yeah and
and so with with me I think it would be
like he would be talking to my English
professor without me even knowing and
being like you know that paper sucks he
can do a lot better than that give him a
C on that one and I was just like I was
like what's good what you HOT like all
of a sudden that class got hard I didn't
know I had no idea and it was just it
was an interesting lucky fortunate place
to be at that time so we're gonna get
back to the Merc but before we do
philosophy I'm endlessly fascinated by
philosophy but I'm also a nerd and kind
of academic and pedantic and have spent
a lot of time in school for people who
are listening to this who are say
already in their careers or maybe
they're in their early 20s thinking of
starting a company but our
entrepreneurial e-either involved or
inclined would you suggest if they don't
have any exposure to philosophy that
they read any particular books or
resources or explore it in any way or
would you say actually you know what
that was an intermediate step to
something else you you would probably
better off
studying XY and Z this is like a starter
kit or a plate something you would
recommend to folks who don't have the
philosophy exposure yeah you know I
think part of it is if you read a book
in isolation it's not as rich of an
experience as discussing those ideas
within that context that said if it's if
you're the kind of person that loves to
read and explore our ideas I mean
there's hardly a better place it's a
matter of finding what you enjoy you
know I I happen to love the problems of
philosophy which Bertrand Russell wrote
sort of about Viktor Stein's ideas but
before vikner Stein published and it's
it's written in plain language it's not
hard to understand certainly Nietzsche
is more like philosophy with some weird
sugarcoating of something on top of it
and man like as a young male you know
reading Nietzsche for the first time I
was like yeah like it's not like
it's that passive like I think people
think of philosophers as like Zen monks
sitting there quietly contemplating the
universe I think what it is is its
people grappling with all the same
questions and curiosity that that we all
have if you pause to think about it
and so there's it's so big you know that
it's it's not just you know Descartes
you know I think therefore I am
it's it's it's kind of every little bit
of that back to like you know read
Lucretius like he had the atomic could
you said all that coming under this
first one to admit the pieces like
Lucretia increase increase yes yeah I
mean you know he luc RIT I us yeah I'm a
terrible speller put it in the show
notes
yeah right but like you know it's like
you you read read that or read this
great book called the swerve which you
know is is you know about this this monk
ages ago that that sort of found that
book and then rewrote it and saved it
for history like that reads like a
murder mystery like you don't
necessarily need to start with the
philosophy you can start with the things
around it but I you know I
like I continue to find serve the world
of ideas endlessly inspirational and and
then by the way you know steal them and
use them in whatever you're doing like
that they're there for you Lucretius lu
CR e TI us titus Lucretius Karis was a
Roman poet philosopher we'll put that in
the show notes the the I wanted is
second Bertrand Russell also I haven't
read Bertrand Russell on so many ages
but it is very digestible it is not
dressed up in $10 words when 10 cent
words would suffice a lot of his writing
is really powerful and I also just want
to mention for folks that and I just
thought about this ages and ages ago I
felt like I had certain gaps in my
education after college and I ended up I
don't know why this didn't occur to me
earlier but somebody mentioned that
Stanford UC Berkeley these top-tier
universities all had extended or adult
education classes taught by professors
and junior professors I mean these this
is the same team whose teaching and
those are very readily accessible
well even MIT OpenCourseWare yep so many
colleges now have taken that model and
put great great great classes online and
you know I know that every now and then
I'm surprised what I what I find on
there and get sucked into like an
all-nighter of taking some college class
you know that I know nothing about and
it's so far over my head but it kind of
refuels you again to go like like there
are huge gaps where I know nothing and
the older you get the harder it is to to
start into something new I find at least
because it feels like the mountains too
big you know
I would I would actually not to pull a
Nick actually series on the contrary on
the contrary sir my book is doing me a
lot of good in my dorm room that's been
I think one of your superpowers is that
you ask the fundamental why questions
about long-standing assumptions or
conventional wisdom in different fields
and the more you have done that the more
obvious it is to you to do it as a
starting point in in a way so let's go
back to the Merc we can go in any
direction of course but yeah you you get
you step into this Lord of the Flies
slash gladiatorial arena with butchers
and PhD he's and so on
then what I got what point is there a
point when you're like okay I actually
do think I could be good at this no for
real no I was down there and I I had
made a fatal error of leaving school and
everyone told me it was a fatal error
and this is Lee you know the little
school yeah and and I I I remember being
down there and you know what I was doing
was so brainless it was literally you
take this piece of paper over to that
guy and then that guy would yell at you
and you would rip the paper out of your
hand and then you go get another one it
was literally that brain-dead and I was
desperately looking to learn what was
going on around me and of course I I
bought books on Finance and commodities
and options and all that and they were
completely ridiculous and opaque and
academic that they look like they had no
relationship to what was going on there
at all I started taking classes that
were run at the merkon Mach trading and
just learning the hand signals and
things like that which were fine but
didn't really teach you how to trade and
I spent you know time interviewing with
big companies like Goldman Sachs and
Societe Generale and whatnot because I
did have the academic background where
I would get the interview I would be
able to take the test I would do well in
their math and psychology tests I would
get offered a job as a trader and then I
would look at the contract this is a key
thing people get out of college they get
offered a job I think I'm the only one
who ever read the employment contract
and what it said in there was basically
like they could do anything they want
with me for three years like I don't
even necessarily need to be a trader
like it's why I was interested in doing
but they could they could ship me to
France and having me do something
totally different
I could be an analyst or you know god
knows what and so when I would question
that there'd be like man you should be
really happy like we had you know 300
applicants for this and we offered eight
positions like just take it and I was
kind of like totally your style like you
know I grew up you know like I'd be
remiss not to say that like my dad
modeled my dad was an entrepreneur by
necessity because his dad died when he
was really young
he fought both at the end of World War
two he was drafted into the Navy at the
end of World War two was dismissed
honorably after 16 18 months because
they were downsizing the Navy and then
he was barely young enough to be drafted
into the Army for the Korean War and
when he got out like you know he had no
usable skills so he went to work at the
grocery store that he started working
out when he was 12 years old
saves up all of his money from the Army
in the Navy and bought the store and so
as I was growing up you know my hero was
my dad who was not an academic who was
not what people would think of as like
an executive in a suit or whatever but
did really well you know he had a bought
a property in real estate he he owned a
temporary labor office that supplied
unskilled laborers to factories and and
conventions and whatnot that was a
really good business you know and he had
a lot of common sense smarts he was
horrified that I didn't go to law school
you know but meanwhile I was modeling
what he did and so when I got down there
I was like you got to own you have to
own your own situation you know and so
when I was offered those jobs I was like
well I don't really see myself working
for someone else you
now and I found a guy who also felt that
way and he was working for a big company
and they didn't want to make him a
traitor
because he was too much of a quant like
he was really well educated he was
really mathematical he wanted prove them
wrong so he took a small amount of money
and started trading currency options and
when I found him I instantly knew that
this was the right person because I
talked to dozens of people and no one
was like him and then he said he didn't
want to hire me like you know why or
anyone how did you meet him do you
remember how you guys yeah I was just
introduced to him through he was back
then they were there you know if you're
a trader or even a trading company of a
clearing firm like goldman sachs at the
time there was a company called first
options and he cleared first options and
back then you would literally have to
take the elevator up to keep punching
all the cards into like a computer that
was you know up on 17 floors away you
know Wow ancient times and I met him
through being introduced to him there
after talking to him I knew he was a
serve geeky intellectual that I that I
needed and then when he told me like
that he didn't want to hire me because
he just hired some clerk I was like no
no no no like I will pay you to work for
you he was like this is really strange
it's like I like a video or six months I
set a goal for myself of getting you
know becoming like getting on a badge it
was called like leasing a seat and
actually trading within a year and I was
like I need to get going on this like I
need someone who can teach me options
and it's fascinating because you know he
he then hired me for I mean I want to
say it was $400 a week or something like
that and you know I stood right next to
him all day every day and he taught me
options theory from scratch better than
any college ever could to the point
where you're looking you know three
derivatives in you know the not just
volatility curve but the curve of the
curve and you know as soon as I started
grasping this and going deeper and
deeper down that rabbit hole
the more the more I liked it as as a
puzzle it wasn't certainly the money had
an appeal but it was also hey here's
this this giant competition it's like
paying a huge multifaceted chess game
that no one's gonna get exactly right
but like I said earlier it's about
making hundreds of decisions a day and
even when you get ten in a row that come
up tails you know the next one is 50/50
you know and that discipline was
interesting that was more about teaching
yourself the psychology of standing
there while everyone told you you were
wrong or you were like physically small
or you were too educated or too serious
I mean you can't imagine how much of a
fraternity house that place was by
everything in Wolf of Wall Street
I have seen I haven't lived but I've
seen it yeah and you know I I started
hiring very shortly after I started
trading about a year later I left and
started my own company with almost
nothing and I hired my first employee
who became my business partner for the
last 25 years and I taught him what I
what I learned and I hired people that I
considered corporate refugees people who
worked for companies and decided that
independence was better why did you
leave after a year you know he he was
moving over to the Chicago Board of
Trade and I had found a couple of
awesome programmers to help build this
Options analysis software and he sort of
offered me up to run like some of the
operations at the Mercantile Exchange
when he went over to trade the bond at
the Board of Trade and you know I mean
he was a really really smart guy and he
made me a deal that when you analyzed it
very carefully got worse over time and I
just kind of went you know I like it's
been great and I've learned a ton and
we've made each other a bunch of money
and it's a win-win but I really wanted
to do my own thing
like I wanted to be the captain of my
own ship I guess and thankfully his
guide Jim Hansen who's still one of my
dearest friends serve had an option to
to stay you know with that company or
come in a completely underfunded company
yeah I mean thinking back it was so
stupid you know from a risk perspective
but it was asymmetric you know far more
upside than downside and it worked out
really well and and we spent most of our
time as we hired people and taught them
how to do this it was mostly like
psychology training it was mostly
standing around after hours and saying
what 7 times 28 and screaming it at each
other like a drill sergeant until the
person couldn't remember what 9 times 3
was anymore
yeah wait why did you do that well you
had to be quick yet to be quick on basic
mental agility I saw so if you brought
if you bought 450 contracts and it was a
20 Delta you needed to be able to do
what's 20% of 450 it's 90 but you need
to do that precisely with numbers that
are not so round right you need to be
willing to not be perfect and you need
to make that decision instantaneously
and realizing that it could cost you 50
to $100,000 if you get it right or wrong
and you and you have to be really really
comfortable with that and so what did we
do well we stood around and we beat we
turned people's brains into mush until
like look I've had people punch me cry
run out it was it was no I mean it
sounds awful but it was it's amazing
training because the rest of the world
moves much slower you so any other
decisions that I've made in business
since then have felt glacial in pace
yeah yeah there's also something to be
said for making the trainer the training
in some or all respects harder than the
competition right I mean the adage of
the more you sweat during peacetime the
less you bleed during wartime I mean the
the best competitors I've met in many
many fields often strive to make their
training in the toil of their
preparation harder than what they expect
to face when they it's why we love
watching big-time sports like when it
matters there are certain people that
you know are you can almost look at them
go at poor that poor person's gonna fade
and then you you hope they don't right
you hope all that training you know pays
off
when you see someone I love golf for all
the same reasons it's like you know just
a series of constant failures and then
so when you look at someone who who can
pull that that rabbit out of the hat you
know at they're exactly the right moment
it's it's pretty pretty wonderful to see
and and I the thing I loved about my
time down there even though I burned out
of it after 10 years is that I there
were moments where I did absolutely mean
I have friends they'll listen to this
and they'll be like oh yeah I remember
that time you happy but you really get
this right you know but I made some
completely stupid decisions but but
mostly on the measure when things got
crazy I was able to perform more than
that I remember like Greenspan's
irrational exuberance speech was like a
formative moment where I kind of went
like wow I can actually I can not only
hang in this environment I can thrive in
it and you know you get home soaking wet
with sweat it was a physical job I guess
with people it was really blue-collar in
a lot of ways and you know it's like I
got home that day and I was like that
was that was what I prepped my last six
years for it was very satisfying
it sounds like an awful it is an awful
thing in a way right like it's just
about pure Commerce it it serves you
know a purpose of price discovery and
all that but any individual person isn't
really the one doing that you know so I
think that there are negatives to the
whole system as well in hindsight but
man at the time it just felt like great
mental training what would you recommend
to people who are listening and are
having this flashback to
the introductory text exchange about
beating the market over a long period of
time who are hoping to become better
investors and you can take that anywhere
you want but are there any particular
tools it's really mental models anything
that you reckon it's really really hard
I think the mental model is asymmetric
risk I always look for something that
the the upside is you know three to four
X the downside obviously quantifying
those is very difficult but that's
that's the key everything I try to do is
asymmetric and then even though nessam
Talib is a bit of a panned antic
goofball on Twitter his book fooled by
randomness is awesome
yeah that was the one that preceded
Black Swan and I think Black Swan is
great it's fine but fooled by randomness
is is I think the better of all his
books because it it just man it just
encapsulates everything that people
price things incorrectly it's a great
scene oh yeah you walk through a casino
and you see everybody pricing their
outcomes incorrectly the entire city is
built on that and you know if you could
get in your head literally literally
literally and and I don't take any
pleasure like people my god you must
have you must love gambling or whatever
and it's like I would never sit down to
a blackjack table because I know that
you know there's a forty nine and a half
percent chance that I'm gonna win and
that's the wrong way yeah the fuller
animus is has come up a number of times
I haven't read it in ages because it is
one of his earlier books but you know
Howard Marks also brought this up
recently when I was chatting with him
and it it is an exceptional book I think
for developing a new lens on life not
just investing when you are investing
for yourself now how do you think about
how do you think about risk because this
is a word that has popped up a few times
but a lot of how do you person how do
you personally think about risk in
or life do you for instance like some
startup founders look at the risk as the
various early-stage startups restaurants
bars this one that you're involved with
and then you play it safe in your other
kind of asset allocation how do you
think about risk in in your life or in
investing yeah that's that's pretty
difficult question I think that yeah I
think that if you look at everything
that I've I've done business-wise
everybody would say that the failure
rate is super high in what we do so
trading these two say one out of a
hundred people that goes down there it
breaks even their first year and fewer
out of that one take another 100 of
those ones and less than 100 of those
becomes a millionaire and I went great
it's like the old Jim Carrey so you're
saying there's chance and then you go to
the restaurant business and people oh
yeah 95% of all restaurants go to
business in their first two years and
I'm like going great you know that's
that's perfect why you why do you have
that response is it because yeah so in
that in then I'm Minister I'm doing a
software startup now don't go for it so
so the higher the smaller the hoop the
more interesting it is to figure it out
and once you're up there and you know
how to jump up through that little hoop
there's there's fewer people playing
that game you know and and the other
thing is I remember right when I was
gonna start building Alinea with with
grant I was talking to a restaurant
owner and by all accounts he was pretty
successful he had four or five
restaurants and one of them I really
liked a lot and we'd go there a lot and
I kind of got to know him a little bit
and he said so you know what are you up
to and I said well actually I'm building
a restaurant now and you looked to me
said ah it's a terrible business you
don't want to do it like incredible
failure rate terrible and I was like why
did you build the next four
whatever what do you how did you respond
to that you know no one does that's kind
of like what you know we'll get to it
I'm sure but that's like the way I was
with the publishing thing it's like it's
like hey man people keep printing books
and yet I can't figure out any of the
information and yet they're gonna give
me like three or four thousand dollars
to write a book like something's remiss
here you know what I mean I've never
written a book before but yet someone's
gonna write me for our thousand our
check there must be a lot of money on
the other side of that bet and and so
consequently like I always try to look
for the hi small hoops and then I spend
my time learning as much as I can and
then I jump through that hoop it's both
more interesting I think and I also
think getting back to the asymmetry of
risk those are the ones that you know
yeah you might have a you know well
first of all do you really have a 95
percent failure rate if you put in all
that effort yeah I don't think so you
know and second of all you know so I
think they priced it wrong so to speak
and then second of all like man that's
that's where the fun is like that gets
you up in the morning and going to work
yeah yeah this is this is where in among
many many other places averages can be
very very misleading right and I always
end up in public q and A's and things of
this type hearing various numbers and
stats thrown around many of which I
think have no basis on any data
whatsoever but there's the we only use
10% of our brands not true there is the
nine out of ten startups fail within the
first year or whatever the yeah yes that
is and the the first question that
occurs to me with a number like the the
latter or as a ratio is well is it
because the model is difficult is it
because startups are inherently that
high risk or is it is are there other
plausible explanations is it that nine
out of ten people who attempt to start a
startup don't do any of the necessary
due diligence correct yes
yeah the number of I you know I've been
on a couple of like graduate school you
know entrepreneurship like you know
contests and whatnot and one of the
things that always happens there is what
I call like the time machine someone
comes up with a business plan that is
like you know you know I'm gonna build a
time machine now of course it's not
really a time machine but I have seen
ones that defy the laws of physics for
example or you know new pipeline
technology but they have no idea like
it's just a pipe dream they've done none
of the engineering you know so you you
kind of look at that and you go you know
you haven't really done the homework yet
at all and then there's a lot of people
that come to me and they've spent like
six months doing their logo and then the
name of the company but they don't
actually have a piece of software yet
right I'm just gonna hire someone to
build that for me I'm an app yeah it's
so many apps pitch to me and you know
they don't know how to build an app but
they've got a logo and an idea and I was
like that's a good way to blow a half a
million dollars on a consultant I get
all that you must get that fifty times
worse yeah I mean dude what what I tend
to get and this is part of the reason
why I stopped all the startup stuff a
couple of years ago is it got to the
point where 90% of the pitches I
received which were unsolicited would be
along the lines of high comma like not
even a first name or be like hi Tim or
hate him even better I am the CEO or
co-founder of X we are raising this at
this valuation we are oversubscribed but
we could squeeze you in for 25k if
you're really interested because we
admire ABC here the docs attached in the
next 60 minutes which might end up it
might default response to anything like
that where people are pressuring me for
a fast decision is no like it's just
right it's like I've lost very little
money saying no to those things but the
the coming back to the the examples that
you were giving and what we were talking
about bridging over to restaurants and
food so you're being told how
restaurants are an awful business food
is an awful business and I remember
someone told me long long time ago
they're like yeah if you want to lose
money go into magazines or restaurants
right and at what point and I have a
little bit of the back story but not all
the details I get at what point do you
decide to go into or get involved with
restaurants and why well so I left
trading in about 2000 to 2001 there was
a you know tough year between 9/11 which
was my father died in February of that
year I was burnt out after you know
going really hard for so long and you
know we built up a pretty good-sized
company too and I'm merged with the firm
New York and I just I kind of needed a
break but didn't know how to how to
really take one at the time and so I
left I left trading and I immediately
kind of panicked because here's
something that I really genuinely
enjoyed but didn't didn't kind of know
what I wanted to do next and started
doing consulting for you know a small
hedge fund and and then you know I just
didn't know what to do and I had you
know an awesome wife and a young son and
things were good you know but I was kind
of panicked I was I was playing golf
with like you know ex-athletes because
who else is thirty four years old and
can play golf on a Wednesday afternoon
and so it was just a weird thing and I
kind of looked at them and I'm like oh
they don't really seem all that happy
even though they're they've got this
lifestyle and so I met Grant Achatz the
chef at dwell dining a trio went to a
lunch there one afternoon that some
friends set up and it was a
transformative experience
it was artistic it was intellectual as
thought-provoking most of all it was
emotional and those were all things that
I would never have associated with
eating a dinner right and so from from a
perspective of like great art
experiences like seeing a great movie or
a great play or going to an amazing
museum opening we kept get drawing back
there like we kept going back and we
would go back so frequently that it was
absurd because you know it's a big meal
and it wasn't cheap and every time we'd
go somewhere else we'd go like wow why
are why is no one else thinking this way
and as I got to know Grant a little bit
I think like sometimes people bring you
know the chef's some wine or beer or
whatever and it's like that's kind of
sand to the beach you know I I would
bring him books and I didn't figure he
had a lot of time to read so I would put
like a post-it note on a page of an old
book so I remember I brought him this
book called the peregrinations of an
Epicure hold on a second the
peregrinations like a peregrine falcon I
don't even know no no no a peregrination
is like a wandering about okay so it was
written just after world war ii by an ex
servicemen and he he kind of goes around
you know Paris I want to say maybe late
40s early 50s I can't recall exactly and
there was a chapter in there on la Pira
Mead which was a very classical
restaurant how the best in the world at
time and he described to me a meal there
in emotional terms that resonated with
what grant was doing even though his
technique is cuisine everything was
completely different and so I literally
just highlight like a couple lines in
there and and give him this book which
was out of print at the time and we kind
of developed this email relationship
back and forth where he would sort of
try out some new food on us and I would
give you know direct honest feedback but
not like oh it was delicious
it was more like it was more like that
you know like you're going for a
provocation there but if you you know
and we would go back and forth and he
wrote at the time on a on a forum called
Eagle 't and i went on there and his
spelling grammar not with withstanding i
mean it was like reading someone whose
just really thinking hard about what
they were doing everything we just
talked about here was this young 28 year
old chef from Michigan who looked like
Captain America who would come out not
you know he was like Hollywood in the
sense of like he was good-looking and
very driven very clean-cut but he didn't
look like you know the stereotype
central casting of a chef right you know
chubby gregarious guy he was really
quiet an introspective shy but then you
read and you know these which are still
up you know you can still google it and
you'd go like you know he'd go on for
like four pages about bread service like
what's the point of bread you know this
is a guy that I could rap you know wrap
my head around and so I remember on
January 20th 2004 my wife's birthday and
she said yeah I want to go back there
and we'd never been in the kitchen
before and they have a table there but
we'd never eaten in there and I remember
I emailed him and said she's definitely
Latvian speaks Japanese and loves Thai
food good luck and I knew
exactly what that would do to him that
would put him into ten days of pure hell
because a human research Latvian food he
would have to read like he would read
you a whole menu 20 courses right and I
didn't know they were gonna put us in
the kitchen and they put us in the
kitchen I mean it sounds like a jerky
thing to do now but we did have a
relationship a little bit at the time
and he served us like the most amazing
meal of my life you know and it started
out with Latvian sorrel soup with
braised ham hocks and you know it had
flavors of the sea which was a Japanese
dish it had a Thai dishes
but it was all in his style and so it
was his own and yet it had elements of
all these things and at the end of that
meal he said to me you know well what do
you think and I had watched the kitchen
and it was like a watchmaker shop it was
not screaming and yelling it is it is
just as its dropped it is so unlike
anything that the vast majority of
people listening to this would possibly
expect right yeah Ramsey is that Gordon
Ramsay
right it is just complete silence it is
like a watchmaking factory it is it is
really something else anyway started to
jump it yeah no no it's it's that's
that's totally fine and so at the end I
said you know I doubt anybody anywhere
in the world had a better meal tonight
and he was like well well thank you and
I said what are you planning on doing
with yourself
you know yeah I was like I had a lot of
wine and I kind of looked at him you
know he sat down with us and I said what
do you what are you gonna do and he goes
well what do you mean I said well you're
not gonna be here forever
and he said well I want to build my own
restaurant I said I'd be I'd be happy to
help you do that and he said what kind
of restaurant you want to build I said I
don't know I've never built a restaurant
before that was it and then like a week
later I got an email with his business
plan I invited him by my house in a year
to the day later of that that was May
4th you know I went back and forth on
email and May 4th
we held a dinner at my house for
potential investors and on May 4th 2005
we opened Alinea that is nuts
in terms of nuts we didn't know each
other that I mean can you put that in
perspective for people I actually did
not realize that was the the timeframe
yeah I mean can you just in the context
of like normal restaurant world we we
argued like so we didn't really know
each other very well but he would come
by my house and he and he didn't let me
let me interject for a second because
you've said we didn't know each other
very well what did you know about each
other
nonetheless that gave you guys the like
the the push like the impulse and the
the sufficient level of trust slash
excitement to actually pursue it right
there had to be something there it
couldn't just be nothing so what was it
you didn't know each other well meaning
maybe you didn't know the full scope of
each other's bad thoughts yeah I mean I
actually studied that like that actually
knew I knew the facts you know and I
knew what he was putting in front of me
but I didn't know him you know like the
way you'd know someone that you're gonna
become a business partner with and I
think he just thought I was rich
yeah I be serious Mike
you know I think everyone else wanted
this is this is really true because he
has said this to me
everyone else wanted to offer him a
restaurant that they had already built
or wanted to build and I actually
answered that question incorrectly the I
don't know is an awesome thing to say
like 90% of the time of your life
right and so when he said what kind of
restaurant do you want to build
I could have waxed on about some dream I
had or just made some up at the
time but I just said like I have no idea
like that's a big question we need to
sort that out I think that was the right
answer for him I think that's all he
needed to know was like okay the guy's
got an open mind he seems to have done
well in business he knows like you know
apparently how to build something well
it was really funny is that the stuff
that I was concerned about which was
like architecture design plumbing you
know building lease all of that he was
like the word oblivious is not too
strong of a word like you know this is
not a criticism of him either right it's
just like he came to my house and he was
just like yeah I you know I want Martin
to design everything Martin Kastner who
was a genius designer has crucial detail
which we've been involved with for 15
years now
he's a like a designer he's like a an
artisan like he built plateware and and
he won the book used to or for the
platter he designed for Thomas Keller
and Daniel Boulud team for the Team USA
and all that now but back then like I
mean this guy's like a design plumbing
or electrical so I would just look at
him going like well no he can't mean we
need an architect and you need to get
like city stamps and all that and all
that so I think grant was just like yeah
you find a place you put tables in it
you you know build a kitchen and you go
you know in terms of like obviously he
knew there were health inspectors and
all that but the process of all this
just about you know you either were
gonna not build it ever eight weeks in
because we were too hated each other
where we were the kind of people that
figured everything out and we just
talked it out like right down to like
what kind of tables
what kind of glassware what kind of this
like
you know we wanted to rethink the why
again of everything like why do you put
a candle on a table why is a candle
romantic like that's a question we asked
why do we need candles that's kind of
like why is that romantic why is why do
people put a little bud vase on a table
why shouldn't that be an edible thing
that'd be cool so so we did all that and
we designed the experience to create
emotional responses from the moment that
you walked in the front door so we
didn't have a podium you know we went
what is a good greeting feel like not
just you know if you're at someone's
house what does that feel like if you're
at restaurant what shouldn't it feel
like well it shouldn't feel like a
computer in front of your face saying
what's your name you know and all that
so we we went through every aspect of
that and you know I lost almost 20
pounds that year not in a healthy way
just like gee seeing the construction I
laid tile in the basement like three
days before we open okay let me pause
for one second so the why question that
comes to mind for me is after the
finance after of battling it out on the
front lines and going through 2001 why
this as your next thing like why why was
this the thing that captured your
imagination you had to know on some
level once you started getting into the
details like I mean this is going
to be that's all in this has to be this
is gonna be all my chips and
energetically so why why this you know
there there are occasional times when
you wake up in the morning and like that
thought comes back to you that that like
hey I'm you know I'm really sucked into
this right you know and for about three
or four months without telling anybody
even you know Dagmara like even not
telling her like telling no one I kept
going like I should build a restaurant
with this guy it would be the best
restaurant in the world if it was done
all the way right and I recognized my
inner voice saying that's a really dumb
idea you know and you don't know what
you're doing I'd never worked a day in
my life and Ross
right and and I also recognized and this
is also a critical I recognized that so
many people built their living room
after they made some money so they went
like oh well I know how to host a good
dinner party and I know Kidd wine so I'm
gonna build me a restaurant and then
they sit there like it's their living
room and that's not good
like I didn't want to be that that DC
guy that built the restaurant because my
ego was was needed to host a party and
so whenever I would kind of leader on
broach that subject and people would say
like well you know I can almost hear
their brain whispering well of course
that's what he's going to do and and and
so that was again not the best of
motivations in the world perhaps but the
honest one that was hugely motivating
eventually but when we first started it
was this nagging thing like I'd wake up
in the morning and I would go you know
I'm not really into what I'm doing right
now and I've just met somebody who's the
best in the world at what they do and no
one knows it yet like and you know
there's probably met that's probably
happen to me I'm really fortunate that
that's probably happened to me seven or
eight times in my life and when it
happens and I meet that person whoever
it may be no matter what they're doing I
pause I kind of acknowledge that
directly and then I just go like you
know we can we you know grab a glass of
wine or coffee or something and like
that's something worth marking and going
like wow this person's really invested
in something and grant had every aspect
of being being that at 28 years old and
and it you know I mean in hindsight like
it looks it looks smart but I got to
tell you it was years before it felt
smart as you mentioned just now maybe
that you've met these people seven or
eight times who are the best in the
world or potentially the best of them
yet among among them but the the key
point that jumps out for me is and the
world didn't know it yet so my question
for you is
that that sort of brings to the
forefront in my mind at least the
question of what is Nick seeing or
feeling that other people are not this
is could you talk to that and I mean
went big is there a feeling or
particular type of observation a
particular type of detail that you
notice in these people that allows you
to Scout the talent where other people
might miss it or not pay enough
attention to it yeah I mean I think
you've written a couple books about
about that it's it's it's definitely
intangible you know it's I think it's
different in every case but it's it's
interesting because you can tell when
someone is fully committed I guess to
their craft or their art or their
business or whatever it is that they're
doing their sport and it's not because
they talk it about it all the time
though of course you know if you if you
push a little they're happy to do so but
it's more that like if you look around
like the vast majority of people are not
fully committed to whatever you know and
I think part of what you do is you try
to steer people to find those things
that that they can commit to or you can
try to lower a barrier to show them like
hey the commitments not as hard as you
think in this particular area right
right but these folks are like they're
all in there ninety nine percent and
that's what they do often to the
detriment frankly of other aspects of
their lives and I guess you get better
at noticing them you know and I mean now
like that's like boy I live for that
like I love reading people that even if
it's not something I'm interested in
that are all in you know and and they're
that's that's an interesting you know I
really have never really thought about
it that way but like it was just very
clear to be that Grant was all in like
if here's the thing if he wasn't to do
with me he was still gonna do it yeah I
was I was a
I was a helper I you know over time I
certainly contributed you know a great
deal to it not just he contribute a
great deal to business and then I also
contributed to the art but that took
time you know but I could tell that he
was all in and and that was fun I mean
it's fun to work with somebody who is
basically like okay man if you're not in
like get out of the way because I'm
still going mm-hmm
and for for anyone who has the
opportunity I don't even know if they
would have the opportunity but to watch
observe grant even for 60 seconds well
chef able on Netflix yes table yeah
great perfect so everybody should have
the experience of observing grant
working and focusing it is I've met a
lot of people who are good at focusing
who have abnormal focusing abilities and
spending the time that we did together
in Chicago and the time that I had to
observe grant is it is a next level of
focus it's it's really hard to
encapsulate in words so chef stable
fantastic people should check it out and
just watch the level of focus that is
permeates
the appearance the air the atmosphere
it's really something else so to that to
that point focus one of the my favorite
aspects of speaking with you and having
conversations is the question the
questions that you raised right like
what candle not just should we have
candles like that's maybe a good
question but it's probably not the right
first question like why do restaurants
use candles in the first place
furthermore wire candles consider
romantic right like kind of stepping the
Attic basic stuff yeah what are other
questions that you asked related to
Alinea or you we could certainly bridge
to two other you know I think it makes
sense to chat about aviary as well but
what are what are some other questions
that that you guys asked that people
might might not think to ask
yeah I mean it you know grant set the
tone for that in our first meeting not
really knowing me and we started talking
but we didn't even know where to start
right and he said well I I know one
thing I want to have wooden tables like
I want to have bare wood tables and I
said why he said well why do tables
why do fancy restaurants have white
tablecloths they literally call it a
white tablecloth restaurant if it's
fancy why and I couldn't really I came
up with dumb answers like oh it feels
good or it absorbs like a spill or
whatever it may be and he said no it's
because the table underneath is a piece
of and he's like yes and you know
that like as soon as you say it everyone
goes oh yeah I knew that and you've been
at weddings and stuff where you feel
under the table and you're like oh it's
plywood right but if you go to like a
really fancy restaurant you feel under
the table guess what also plywood just a
little thicker and he's like you know
when you rest your arms on the table
even if it doesn't come forefront in
your mind you kind of subconsciously
know that they're kind of fooling you
and he's like why can't we just have
like black beautiful tables it'll show
the food grade he'll show the plate
we're great and then I kind of went like
well yeah but like you know the Health
Department doesn't let you put in
Chicago doesn't let you put silverware
right on the table and if you put a
glass there the condensation will form a
little ring and then you have a ware
issue but you'll save seventy thousand
dollars a year in laundering Linens and
so we started going like well how did we
solve the water problem well you create
a fridge that's just above the duty
point 44 degrees you know in the winter
maybe a little warmer in the summer
because it's higher humidity in Chicago
and you just get rid of ice
it's you know it says so you have these
cascading decisions that like become
part of the art of the place that some
of them start from like a really
practical thing like hey we want to have
a quality table and then all of a sudden
you need a little pillow that the
silverware goes on because that Martin
designed because you can't put video
when I have placemats that's too cheap
so all of a sudden we had to design like
you know a silver
older so it just became this cascade of
like interesting little art projects
that were there for good reasons and
really created a unique atmosphere and
it was like well those things like we
never tested it until the day we opened
like you couldn't test those things and
the very first guy through the door was
is now a famous chef chef Sean Brock of
husk antastic yes I was seen as Matt he
was not yet a chef then 2005 and he was
the first guy through the door and he
wrote this giant blog post and he got it
with pictures and everything you can go
see it and every single thing that we
hoped would create an emotional you know
trigger an emotional reaction it's
almost all they're like I remember going
home and seeing it the next day and
going wow like that should actually work
you know and it's like right down to the
front hallway that was you know a
reverse perspective and I'll stolen from
Short Cathedral and and and inverted you
know so all of my interests of
architecture and art and science and all
the grants you know food and all that
like all came together in like a
year-long conversation on how to do
something and we really fought with the
architect and designers and and all that
because people would tell us the
practical reasons why you needed to do
this or that and we would just go nope
no host and like you know we wanted to
greet people in an open way and so just
little things like that and then we've
taken that on you know through
everything that we've we've done where
we took you know seven years six years
to build our next place because we
didn't have that idea that kept us up at
night again and so you know when we did
then we did it and I think I think
editing editing yourself and each other
is in an open way is really really
painful but really really important and
coming back to something you mentioned
related to the living room the the well
off aha yeah
who then creates a an art project that
is not maybe beautiful but is most often
not a viable business what how did you
apply those questions and rethink the
business model to make any of this work
financially yeah well I mean you don't
want to be a dilettante right and and so
you know my biggest fear is that they
would work in an artistic way but
wouldn't work as a business and so you
know the the the answer is at the
beginning we didn't I didn't do much I
handled all of our marketing and PR like
I wrote everything you know myself
really thought about open sourcing the
the building of the restaurant you can
still go on line and see the the
original business plans and what logos
we were considering using and the Test
Kitchen which was in my house you know
we didn't tell anyone at the time but
that was my house at the time and and
see the development of this restaurant
and I felt like the open source movement
in that way was a good model for what we
were trying to accomplish and part of
that was people would say like a
restaurant like this can't make money
and you know I wrote this little
spreadsheet that I called the universal
restaurant calculator and can people
find that online no no no but it would
be very unimpressive if they could but
it was it was basically like how many
covers pronoun I mean this is back of
the envelope stuff how many covers per
night can you do what's the track
average for food check average for
beverage what are your food costs
beverage cost labor cost was insurance
cost you know your your lease your rent
like all those things right and I had
enough experience with most of those
things to at least give good estimates
to it and so what I started doing is I
started modeling other restaurants using
the universal restaurant calculator
I had again this goes to the
transparency of data I had real data for
only two restaurants and from those two
I would then make assumptions about
restaurants like the French Laundry
where grant used to work well the
greatest restaurants in the history of
America certainly and you know I came up
with a number that grant went there's no
way their revenue is that higher they
make that much money that's impossible
and it was really funny because years
later you know I now work with with chef
Keller and he's he's a friend all these
years later and I literally pulled that
out one day with grant being there and
went like how close am I on this back in
2005 and he's like oh you're within like
2 or 3 percent yeah
and grant was just like and it's I'm
talking about back of the envelope stuff
and so you know you asked like where can
people start to start a business start
on the back of an envelope like one of
my favorite exercises is to sit in a
restaurant or a small business of some
sort and just literally do the back of
the envelope that is the kind of
calculation my dad called it the two
shoebox method put me through college
right like money coming in in 1 3 bucks
money going out the other whatever's
left is profit you know um you know
start that basic and and we did that and
I didn't really think about the we did
well but we didn't make a ton of money
Alinea cost 2.2 million dollars to build
I put up a little over a quarter of that
myself and found investors for the rest
all of whom I knew and you know in the
first year we did you know we made about
four hundred fifty to five hundred
thousand dollars on four or five million
dollars in sales not a great return not
a terrible return we then won you know
best restaurant in America from Gourmet
magazine and I was horrified that we won
that frankly I remember grant called me
and said yep I just got a call from Ruth
Michael and like we had some stated
goals of like how would we know if this
is a success and one of the things we
wrote down was Ruth Michael declares it
the best restaurant in America and we
wrote that because in 1997 she wrote the
most exciting place to eat in America is
the French Laundry and grant was there
and cooked that
and said that the energy of having
someone that he respected so much
because Ruth is just a great writer
she's one of the unimpeachable food
critics in the history of America and
having her write that New York Times
propelled that restaurant to its
permanent status I think that can't
happen nowadays honestly for other
reasons but this is kind of pre-pre you
know internet pre yelp all that and then
of a sudden we got that and I was like
horrified because you know one of the
goals was completed so early we would
have we wouldn't have our like our
lodestar you know mm-hmm and so he was
like dear God can you let me enjoy it
for like a minute you know to you happy
but I was also like oh no now what do we
do enough of this I need to find
happiness and get this other happiness
out of my out of my face actually that
it's often the process is is so
rewarding that when you get something
done it can be a letdown you know and I
wanted that process to go and then
unfortunately six months later grant was
diagnosed with stage four cancer and
given six months to live and so weirdly
that was the moment where after he was
going through treatment where I started
going into the restaurant at night
because remember I'm not a service
professional I was running the business
of the restaurant I was not going in at
night and asking really dumb questions
again and you know weirdly our goal was
to keep Linea open for when he came back
and my due he only missed like you know
12 days 14 days of service during really
intense chemo and radiation and but he
was given six months to live and you
know when people are in that situation
and their livelihood is tied to this
restaurant even despite their loyalties
often time
they just need to find another job
because they're like hey in four months
this place is gonna be closed so it was
and in the midst of that we decided to
do our first book really to chronicle
you know his his you know what he
accomplished because for him he felt
like that be his legacy he thought he
was going to die he was told he was
going to die so in the midst of managing
a self-created self-published book and
trying to do that differently and then
keeping a dwindling staff motivated
trying to let him know that it would
still be there when he got well all that
I started going this place is run in
strange ways man this industry is is is
not run right you know and I started
asking like basic questions like if we
have a wait list for a hundred people on
a Wednesday why do we do 74 people on a
Wednesday but 86 on a Saturday and the
answer was because our incentives were
misaligned you know the service industry
as a whole can't run at a hundred
percent every single day of the week
unless they're incentivize to do so and
you could go like well yeah but every
server there I'll make an extra hundred
bucks a night or whatever but they're
kind of going like look if every night
was Saturday I'd be dead it's really
hard work you know so you need to figure
out ways of load-balancing that and
making every day the same and you end up
way ahead so from a business perspective
that's when my sort of self education in
this industry came came forward and it
came forward in a way that I think I was
less patient with everything because we
were also going through this really
difficult emotional time and so
consequently when I didn't get answers
that made any sense
instead of being diplomatic about it I
would just be like well that's stupid
you know which cut some of the normal
social filter off and I'm sure it wasn't
a pleasant time to be around anybody but
I also think it was accepted within that
environment at that time because
everyone knew what we were going through
and so when we you know
years years later when we finally like
we're kind of like hey we've got some
ideas to build next and the aviary
that's when I kind of went like well
we're gonna do things totally
differently here and anyone who's not on
board even though they work for us like
if you're not on board all the way in
like on getting rid of normal
reservations and not using telephones on
doing all these things I'm not you know
you just we don't have a place for you
here
and man it really worked you know that
was the basis of you know I talked to
every software company in the industry
asking for their API is asking to build
essentially what's options pricing
software on top of reservation systems
and OpenTable told me no and the POS
systems told me no I called theaters and
what like what ticketing system do you
use and and all those told me no and so
I heard a single programmer and he and I
in six weeks built a really rudimentary
booking system but the first day we
turned it on we sold 562 thousand
dollars of tickets to a restaurant okay
so pause here way ahead no no no this is
great this is great so a few a few
things for folks who are not familiar
API application programming interface
it's how you can effectively link into
someone else's software a POS point of
sale not piece of but it is a piece
of they also be what was what were
the design specs that you were looking
for in other words before you get to the
five hundred thousand-plus yeah yeah the
snapping fingers like what were you
trying to fix or what were you trying to
create so I get a lot of grief for this
for saying this in the industry and in
the press but basically whenever you
make a restaurant reservation one of the
two of you talking is lying to each
other if you think about it nor other
industry a form of entertainment which
dining out is a form of entertainment
I know it's sustenance I know there's so
much culture embedded in it and all that
but you could eat at home right no other
form of entertainment you just call them
up and say hey will the seat to the
Bears game or the Cubs game
or the Opera and I'll show up around
7:30 and then they tell you yeah yeah
we'll have a seat ready for you at 7:30
and then when you get there they go oh
you know what go wait over there for 30
or 40 minutes because we're running a
little behind tonight you know the
reason that they're running behind is
because they overbooked because about 15
to 18 percent that people just don't
show up so they over booked they also
know that if they tell you that they'll
really seat you at 9:00 and you wanted
an 8:15 you'll just go the restaurant
down the street from them that will lie
to them right right so so they so they
do that and ultimately it's just bad all
around it's bad for the restaurant it's
wasteful for food and it's bad
hospitality like and that's like there
are so many pop culture references and
an entire sitcom you know episodes built
around someone trying to get into a
restaurant right it's absurd it's
completely absurd and you know I looked
at our no-show rate at Alinea
data-driven tracked it I looked at our
what we call short seated tables like
the number of tables that were for
people but only two showed up and the
dirty secret there is like people would
go like well what do you have available
well I have an 834 for ok we'll take
that and they never intended to bring
the other two people well that's just as
bad as a two-top no showing we only have
74 people in there and so it's a yield
match or 74 seats so it's a yield
management problem and so we five to
eight percent of our revenue every night
was was being lost to that transaction
that was a non transaction right and so
I wanted to figure out ways to do two
things one way to figure out ways to
make it transactional because again you
asked about professor Thaler one of the
key tenants is a little bit of skin in
the game right when people have a small
vested interest in something in the
outcome of something or even if I gave
you a pencil as a gift and then 30
minutes later I want to take it back you
will get so mad even though you didn't
care about that pencil right right what
was that yeah give me a gift now he's
pulling it back you know it's like the
expected it's like the expected value of
mug if you ask them how much they would
spend to buy the mug versus giving them
the mug and saying how much will you
accept to sell it you know the
differential yes huge so you know a that
came to me one day because I my my kids
wanted to go see a movie at night that I
did not want to go see and I was really
really like I would have easily paid 50
bucks to not go to this movie right yeah
and then my wife basically says hey well
let's go to that movie so I go on
Fandango I buy four tickets 60 bucks
whatever it was and like 5:30 tonight
it's pouring rain and everyone's napping
and they're like yeah I don't want to go
and I'm like get your asses in the car
we're going to the movie man
now I easily pay about $60 to not go to
the movie but once I had the sunk cost
of of paying for the movie my psychology
totally flipped like and I literally
irrationally made everyone go to the
movie like which weirdly cost you know I
mean from an emotional family standpoint
all bad all the way around right and so
I thought about it and I was like wow
what if people what if people put down a
small deposit on times when demand
exceeds supply like right so Saturday
night 8 o'clock great that's off that's
the best seats at the Opera House let's
see if people prepay for that or put
down 20 bucks for it that's fully
credited at the end of their meal it's
not a cover charge I'm not trying to
squeeze people on the actual cost of the
meal I'm just trying to go like yeah
let's see if people will make a
commitment and everybody told me no no
one's gonna do that like this is not the
way it works but if you look back
historically this is the interesting
part again it's about like digging in
deep on something if you look back
historically restaurant reservations
started with the telephone and at the
time that we were starting to do this
the telephone was dying and I didn't
know that at the time you know I was 8
years ago but I have a computer in my
pocket and if you ring me and I don't
know your number I don't want to talk to
you I don't answer it
I'd much rather receive like a little
piece of text letting me know what's
going on
than a phone call similarly like calling
a restaurant is an antiquated thing to
do at this point but long before the
telephone people got room and board and
what room and board was literally it was
like you go to an inn and you you get a
room for the night and then do you need
food okay well you get a board of food
that was literally it and you'd prepay
for it
mm-hmm and so you know there was
hundreds of years of that long before
there was a telephone and people called
and said yep Mike you know I'd like to
eat at your restaurant sure it will let
you in and so as the technology for the
telephone is morphed into you know what
we all have in our pockets now I just
wanted to update that whole transaction
and so I also wanted to acknowledge that
Tuesday nights should be cheaper than a
Saturday night so it has to work in both
ways I always thought uber could to fix
their their surge pricing issues by
having discounted pricing when there was
no demand like just new pricing in two
directions and if you move pricing in
two directions then like that whole
argument goes away right and so so we
did that we we we priced out different
prices by day of the week and times a
day so 5:00 p.m. on Wednesday at Alinea
is still cheaper than 8:00 p.m. on
Saturday by a lot by eighty to a hundred
dollars a person Wow and and you know
what happened and this is now we have
you know hundreds of restaurants doing
this on our software called talk what
happens is people buy the most expensive
seats first and the cheapest seats first
which is exactly what you'd expect
actually right because there's some
people who are price conscious and go
like wow this is a really expensive meal
but holy cow I don't really care if I
eat at five o'clock on a Tuesday great
like I can say 400 bucks and then
there's some people that go like I only
eat at a p.m. on Saturday well okay
that's fine
pale or more or yeah or they're
attracted to the fact that it is the
most expensive sure that happens too and
then there's there's a whole bunch of
tools that over time we built on top of
that to sell wine pairings or sell books
you know we sell twenty linear books a
day and check out with the booking
process mm-hmm
that's all done because we're not going
to exit through the gift shop at Alinea
it's a Michelin 3-star restaurant so I
was like we would subtly have like one
book like near the restrooms that people
could peruse but it didn't say like by
the book or anything like that so
typically we'd sell like one or two per
night now on checkout when you book
Alinea it says hey would you like to buy
a linear book personalized and 20 people
at night get it that is four hundred
thousand dollars in revenue are you here
yeah that's incredible easy right and
it's amazing to me that no one did that
beforehand because ultimately people
can't buy what they don't see and people
don't want to be up sold inside of a
restaurant there's nothing worse in my
mind then you know some places that
today's special is today's special and
it's real and you kind of know that but
sometimes it's just the old fish right
Sunday night these things and like I
think no restaurant wants to like raise
their hand go yep
that's all true like we were aligned to
our customers and and we're not gonna
really seat you at a 15 and so I think
when I said that like you can look back
through some articles
I remember that there's an article I
think it was in GQ that they interviewed
like a grizzled veteran you know and you
didn't use his name that said you know
I'm over booked in a bar to wait and has
always worked for me
and I was just like how does that not
sound like terrible hospitality to
everyone reading that you know yeah for
sure yeah yeah there's so there's so
many systems that have similar
overbooking load balancing issues right
you look at Airlines you look at
hospitality yep my dentist yeah I have a
great dentist they only do it via phone
call or email and so I have to play a
guessing game it's like going into a
clothing store and going like yeah I'm
looking for a blue v-neck cashmere
sweater like now don't have one guess
again just tell me what day you could
clean my teeth show me and I'll just go
online and hit the button
[Laughter]
when you then debuted the the the
ticketing option if I'm if I'm labeling
it properly how did you prime the pump
for that was there anything did you need
to prime the pump to have this what
seems like certainly a windfall yeah we
did a video where you know next
restaurant was about a restaurant that's
always new essentially like what's one
of the big problems of the restaurant
industry well when you opened a new
restaurant doesn't matter what it is
people are going to show up for like
five or six months and then after that
you know you guys struggle to like get
regulars and you know I find new
audiences and all that but people like
the new quote unquote right the other
problem is is that our own staff and
shafts were the kind of people who I
said to grant one time he cooked this
amazing French dish for me at Alinea
right in the middle of his sickness
because I had driven down from Michigan
I've never eaten before after in the
Alinea kitchen but he whipped up this
little French dish for me of duck and I
was like man let's open a French
restaurant someday and he went like yeah
we'll get bored after six months and
then I was at one of our chefs homes on
a day off Tuesday and he made he loves
Thai food and he made this amazing Thai
meal amazing and I was like wow like I
had no idea these guys were so versatile
you know and then it made sense hey
these are passionate amazingly talented
people and it kind of dawned on me like
let's just change the restaurant every
four months like you know let's do and
then we dwelled on that Friday year
thinking like it was kind of impossible
to do and then you know Grant said I
said well like let's start with a French
menu he's like well what does that mean
like there's southern France there's
Loire Valley
there's France that's the nouvelle
cuisine and there's friends from like
you know a hundred years ago totally
different and I was like yep Paris 1906
I don't need to explain to you what that
is you'd want to eat that if I just said
like if someone said hey new restaurant
opening what's the menu it's Paris 1906
I feel like cool like I want to do a
little time travel and see what that
like and so as soon as we had like a
city and a time we instantly knew that
was the idea that kept us up at night
you know where we went like wow look at
all these different places we can travel
and what does that restaurant look like
and how do you create a kitchen
versatile enough to make all these
different cuisines and how do you make
it not feel like Disneyland where one
time you have a theme of Paris and the
next time you have a theme of Japan so
you have to go with like an austere
minimalism you know and is this
particular reason why he chose the year
1906 you know I'm doing some research I
may get the exact date wrong because
this is eight years ago I did the
research but I believe the send flooded
in 1908 it somewhere around there and so
Escoffier like the father of french
cuisine was at the ritz then and that
was kind of like the height of that era
of cuisine and then after the Sun
flooded that's where you got serve your
brasseries and bistros because they had
to kind of go to a more casual it opened
up for more people it might took the
price point down it made it more
approachable and it wiped out dozens of
these fancy restaurants and so like rank
got cheap but no sudden like hey like
we're gonna get this new style of
restaurant that's roughly as I recall it
somebody's gonna listen to this and tell
me I'm all wrong but that's where we
landed because we could do this
Escoffier menu and boy we argued about
that too like in their blenders then so
so like electric blenders so I mean we
just so you wanted to mimic the
production well I did grant did not so
so we we we were I remember we were at a
we invited the press to a practice
finish like hey pal you don't have to
make the first like should we make it
intentionally worse than we can yeah the
recipes were really vague they didn't
call for salt yeah so so in the middle
of this press dinner where we had like
the New York Times that we had all sorts
of these people there which will never
do again right that was just a genuine
error like and like like we
still arguing out conceptually what this
thing would be and then we served dinner
and and we were like openly Ark he'd
come out of the kitchen and we would
openly argue about it you know and this
is at the press dinner yeah yeah he
brought the soup out and it was like you
know he was like I was like oh they they
must have used like the actual blenders
right like modern blenders because it
was like the mouthfeel is like perfect
right and so I was like oh you you used
the blenders you know and he was like
the recipe didn't call for salt either
did it but I should I have not used that
and had it taste like and then I
was like well maybe you don't know that
they didn't have refrigeration then
either and they packed the vegetables
insult as a desiccant and so they were
almost all pre salted by the time they
get to Paris and that was it like people
were just like these guys don't like
each other but that was that was that's
our method like that's what we did you
know and I mean to the day we opened we
we had those those arguments and then
you know in terms of the software like
man like I didn't sleep for a week we
set it up on Rackspace it didn't work
right I had never done anything like
that before
you know it was like no one would help I
think like like you know nobody would
help no one we might say nobody would
help you mean competitors potential I
don't know I like these are the I got it
speak why wouldn't they help don't I you
know like in the case of OpenTable they
had a monopoly right so why that makes
sense to me that mean yeah um in terms
of everyone else I think they didn't
just didn't get it but even people
within my own company thought this was a
fool's errand you know like grant for
sure like he will fully admit this now
thought it was a terrible idea why did
he think it was a terrible idea because
it's not hospitable it's not hospitality
it's not it's not it's not it's low
touch not high touch correct man and and
hugely the case where you know also in
the price is different every day like
are people going to get that and I just
kept looking to other industries and I'm
like no one has a problem with it when
they go to a baseball game they're us
the you know above the dugout and then
like the guy who's in the third deck
back row looks down and go I like I like
he totally stole that ticket from me two
different price points you know and I
just feel like people inherently get
that without having to explain it to
them how enough how far in advance of
the open haha were you were you hoping
to launch the software and when did you
end up launching the software
yeah I launched it about seven hours
before the first dinner holy
I hope to have done it four to five
weeks ahead of that it was literally a
one-man operation plus me like one
programmer and me when we launched it
Rackspace this is 2010 I'm not saying
anything bad about rocks bases I didn't
I probably set it up wrong 2010 it did
not like its supposed to auto load
correct and self propagate and it
neither happened I was expecting we had
17,000 people on our email list that it
signed up on the website to like be
notified when when the bookings went on
sale and I was expecting maybe you know
700 show up like should be fine and
something like 8 or 9,000 showed up and
everyone just kept hitting the Refresh
key and here's another fatal error of
stupidity and and this is not the way
our software is built now because we
have professionals here but basically my
admin login was on the very same server
yes everybody's public access Oh God so
I couldn't even go into configure pick
it up so I this is that I couldn't
answer like hundreds of angry emails all
at once so I created a Facebook group
for the business which in 2010 not very
many people did and so if you go back
and scroll all the way down to the
beginning of that you'll see me going
like hey if everyone could please stop
refreshing I can sort this out and what
was really cool is that people felt part
of something they felt like wow holy
this guy is actually doing this
himself we're part of this experiment
and we're on the inside of it I got a
lot of empathy from the customers
even though they were the ones that were
unable to get what they wanted and then
when it finally started working I mean I
literally not showered in five days
I pizza boxes Langer it looked like a
bad movie startup thing I had a beard
like I was you know just strung out
manic and I remember I called grant and
it was opening day and he said how many
should I prep for I said prep for full
like because if not we'll turn on the
phones but I didn't tell him was I
didn't order the phones because I didn't
want to have a fail-safe yeah you'd burn
the ships yeah oh yeah I would I just
wanted to make sure it I forced myself
to work so we had no phone line and I
when it started working I would double
click you know one of the functions was
I could double click on a table and if
it was yellow it was held the public can
see it I could make it available it up
by double clicking it would turn green
and then when it was sold it would turn
red but the first time I did that to act
more inventory out and clearly things
were working they turned red so fast I
thought it was broken and so then I went
into the credit card processing and saw
oh my gosh someone bought that that fast
and I called grant I said dude you gotta
come to my house and he was like we're
opening a restaurant in like six hours
what's going on I said as the guy who
helps save your life getting a
tax he can't come over here because I
need to show you something and he looked
at me and kind of went like what is
wrong with you right and and I took him
upstairs to my office and I said I
explained what I just to him I just
explained to you and I said click on one
of those make it available and he said
which one I go anyone in the next month
and he clicked like three weeks out at
9:30 and it instantly turned red and in
another window I had the credit card
thing up and I go look mr. Jones bought
that and he went really I'm like yep
there are you know four thousand people
waiting for you to do that right now and
that was the moment at which I I was
basically like this is the best thing
I've ever built because because it was
it was it was functionally different
than
any way that anybody was doing this it
wasn't novel
it was just applied in a novel way and
so you know what was interesting is that
of course the software itself sucked but
as a proof-of-concept it was awesome
yeah quick question on that if you're
comfortable answering how much how much
money had you put into developing the
software yeah roughly I'm gonna say a
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars
yeah okay so in your mind were you
completely confident it would work or
and there's it doesn't have to be a or B
there could be cdef or were you like you
know what for 115 K or whatever it might
be even if you budgeted for less and it
over an the even if there is a 20%
chance that this works is it is worth
risking the hours in time because it
will so completely transform what we're
doing and if it fails who cares
correct yeah the latter one yeah again
it's about the asymmetric risk right it
was also about this thing that as I dug
into how a linear ran there's like
things that you can fix and control and
there's things you can't write and this
was the one that you know I would answer
phones Alinea and I would it was like
being a therapist people would go like I
would like to you know make a
reservation on my anniversary you know
seven weeks from now on a Thursday and
you're like I'm really sorry sir it's
totally full and our percent time they
thought you were lying to them and and
and so consequently like I realized that
we were saying no to people more than we
were saying yes and that even when we
said no in a nice way and took ten
minutes to do so people thought that we
were lying or that they weren't
important to us or any of those things
and so I felt that transparency was
actually more important than the actual
money and at the actual yield management
I felt like like allowing people to see
the entirety of the inventory was the
most important thing and I had this real
same thing with like you
the trading markets they've moved to
more and more and more transparency more
and more speed this is true across every
industry and I just felt like wow this
industry I found myself in was so
backwards and so I just wanted to make
the whole thing more transparent and so
even if it didn't go beyond my own
restaurants I was totally fine with that
in fact I didn't do anything with it for
four years and I didn't really intend on
making it you know a software product I
intended on fixing my own problems and I
think often that's where that's where
good ideas come from Oh super often yeah
the scratching of your own itch at least
you know you have a market of one guess
guaranteed market of one and I also want
to point out we're talking about
asymmetric risk earlier and you're like
well I want to stand to make three to
four X what I stand to lose and if you
run the math and I'm sure I'm missing a
lot of subtleties here but when you said
we booked 500 NEX thousand dollars and
it caused 115 like we're kidding
very much within the ballpark of that
but I didn't even like I mean well I
mean since then it's like we've taken
our margins at our restaurants from 10
to 12 percent to you know at times in
good months 20 to 25 percent in an
industry that over the last five years
if you read I give a talk called Tuesday
is not Saturday and seven things you
already know but are doing nothing about
it's a talk that I give to the
restaurant industry and you know one of
the things that that I point out in
there is that you know there's so many
obvious things that you could be doing
to improve your hospitality to improve
your booking process to get rid of food
waste but people tend to just kind of
move along because it's a really chaotic
environment it's hard to make change in
it because every day is game day like
you wake up every day and hundred people
are gonna come through the door and if
your fishmonger doesn't show up all you
need to figure out what to do with that
you know and so it's it's not really
about the return on that one investment
at that one moment it's more like you
know a thousand small improvements over
time and you know what if I
look back at that system that I built
then compared to what we have now you
know it's a minuscule part of what it
turned into
but it was the seed of an idea which is
more important which is hey let's let's
shake things up and then I got a great
CFO who was at Bain consulting and he he
came on to like help manage the building
of the project of next and when he
started wanted to build out a business
team I was like great like run with it
and so we've built out food cost
analysis that uses Marimekko charts and
it's totally different because it's
visual and you give that to the chef it
uses what charts ah Marimekko if you
have if you don't know Marimekko if you
get nothing out of this one of the
greatest visualizations in charts that
you could like you know do an excel or
whatever hard to do vocally but imagine
a square where each of your x-axis is
the percentage of let's say food costs
and then each square within there is
like no meat or produce but the whole of
the square is a hundred percent the
y-axis is a hundred percent of one
metric and the x-axis is a hundred
percent of another so you could kind of
look at any given square and see how
much that impacts the whole it becomes
like a big lego building with different
colors if you give a busy chef four
hundred receipts and say hey every
Friday look through all these and you
know figure out what we're spending too
much on or worse hey your food costs
last month or 36% I need them at 32%
you can't take percentages to the bank
let's talk about dollars let's see where
we can save some dollars or the revenue
who could have just gone down that month
for whatever reason it's August in New
York and so it's not really a good way
to look at it but you give this person
this this chart this Marimekko now
they're like oh i'm with his name yeah
it's ma RI m EK KO chart is that right
again not good I think so there is a
Google result which is how to make a
Marimekko chart in Excel so I'm guessing
that's probably it there's some that is
in YouTube videos as well so I'll put
this
show notes for people man I gotta tell
you like from a utility perspective you
show that to a person you explain it
visually like when you see it it makes
much more sense and they instantly get
it and they look at it they're like oh
there's no way I spent that much on
facial last month you know and this can
be this can be used for things outside
okay everything yeah it's not just food
not just restaurants oh no no it's it's
just a great visualization of utility
and like consultants love it and I gotta
tell you I don't love consultants in
general but if I've learned anything
from from the best consultant that I've
ever hired like who's now my partner in
CFO he you know he came in with this as
soon as I saw it I was like how did this
not enter my life until my 40th year
this makes no sense you know it's just
incredibly useful but my point is is
that we we kind of went through
everything in the restaurant and went
like well what are the biggest spending
areas that we can like analyze and it's
true in any endeavor that you're doing
you you know there's no point looking at
the dimes if you've got something it
costs a thousand dollars start there so
you know and this you know getting into
like our thoughts on our publicity our
PR like we don't have a professional PR
person and haven't in 14 and a half
years we we don't spend money on any
promotions other than social media and
then with the social media we track all
of that you know we can see what our ROI
is on a boosted post we can see what our
ROI is if we advertise on your podcast
and you know those are that's that's why
these mediums are working is because
they're measurable mm-hmm you know I was
looking up just as you were chatting and
as I was also looking for a Marimekko
quote that I think applies and you may
certainly feel free to disagree if it
applies very well to a lot of the
breakthroughs they that you have
experienced and also
helped to catalyze in a lot of what
you've done it's quote from Charlie
Munger who for those who don't know you
should definitely take a look at poor
Charlie's Almanac he's the the the
right-hand or I shouldn't even say that
he is the investing partner of Warren
Buffett and fascinating fascinating
human being but one of one of the quotes
of his that I really returned to a lot
when I think I might be outsmarting
myself in some way or in general as a
reminder is quote it is remarkable how
much long-term advantage people like us
have gotten by trying to be consistently
not stupid instead of trying to be very
intelligent yeah because you you as you
noted earlier you have these practices
that are being implemented by other wise
in many cases smart people who have just
not taken the time to ask why are we
doing this why does this exist as the
thing why does like you pointed out it's
so obvious once you reframe it like you
walk into a clothing store and they're
like okay what are you looking for nope
sorry guess again it's like that's
ridiculous
right yeah and yet that's exactly the
way it works in many other places yeah
yeah and that's you know once you start
down that road of thinking that way it
will drive you a little nutty because
you can't do every business you know and
you know there's a couple things that
I've got in my back pocket that I'm kind
of like you know one day I'm gonna are
betrothed ruffles because it's like
there's an opaque market that's absurd
like you know it's like here's an
example I'm gonna give somebody out
there call me up because this is a real
business idea and I've been wanting to
do it for years but you know black and
white truffles not the kind not the
chocolate ones but the kind that the
dogs dig up in France in Italy are as
expensive as the most expensive drugs in
the world
you order them as if it were an illegal
drug of course they're perfectly legal
but you call up a truffle dealer and you
go like we all what do they cost well
they're you know six hundred and fifty a
pound right now for black truffles 1604
why
you try to talk them down a little bit
you make sure that you get the best
quality because they were Alinea and we
will ship you back this stuff we don't
like and all that and then in an
unmarked box stacked with newspaper will
come $20,000 of truffles it's for like a
week by the way like not like this is
not like a big supply and is completely
opaque as a market there's no mycologist
touching these there are knockoffs from
not knockoffs there's different species
and quality from Australia from
Tennessee from from China etc etc that
they cut into it sound familiar
and and like it was Mike we spend a lot
of money on truffles every year and try
to figure out what the US market in the
fall truffle season is worth you can't
it's exactly like publishing you can't
find numbers you know and so whenever
ice whenever I see something like that
I'm like someone's guarding their their
golden goose you know right whatever
whatever it's a black box you're like I
feel like I am NOT on the best side of
this trade that's right and and that's
that's what I did
you know I did a closing insulator
Network between the Merc and the AMEX to
arbitrage ETFs to get rid of the phone
brokers in the middle that took me like
a year and a half to get through the
murk and Amex powers that be read like
most of the CFTC so when they would tell
me it's not like in the rules are not
legal or CFTC Chicago trade this is the
federal commodities Trading Commission I
say okay it's like the SEC but for
commodities I gotcha
and you know again sit don't actually
read that some day like what's amazing
is that the experts never it's like it's
like the members of Congress who don't
read the bill and then if you ask them
detailed instructions on it they're like
oh yeah I don't really know but the
general tenor is this or that the people
who were governing the exchanges had
never read the rules so they just quote
to me let me just quote to me like
you're all it's against the rules I'd be
like well you're the seventh volume
police show me where if not I'm gonna do
it you know and so similarly like like
truffles same thing the the you know the
booking for the restaurants the same
thing open table out of monopoly they
wouldn't tell you who your customers
were they would sell your customers they
still do two other restaurants if you
you know if you're full one night
they'll just send you down the street to
a Japanese restaurant down the street
they don't care so I wanted to get rid
of all that so I built the software for
that truffles I will someday build the
truffle exchange so you question for ya
the this is this is this is something
also for this is maybe just turning this
into a therapy session slash coaching
sessions for myself but I get attracted
like a moth to the flame to puzzles and
I've got a puzzle no no no I don't need
any puzzles I need more puzzles but you
there are many many black boxes out
there right you you have truffles and
like you said it's like what's the
market size of the truffle exchange @x
point in time don't know right although
you guys is one establishment or
multiple styles runs by a lot there
might be a hundred different black boxes
like that that you run into how do you
choose the black boxes worth trying to
shine light on like a detective because
the it's going to consume energy it's
going to consume time how do you pick
and choose which to go after it's it's
it's it's like the manic test right like
it's like the one that bothers me the
most like I kind of start doing you know
and then you know it's iterative from
there like sometimes you find yourself
in a construction of your own doing that
was accidental mm-hm like all of a
sudden you know you kind of opened your
mouth and said something like the
truffle thing and all of a sudden like
well okay I guess we're building the
truffle exchange you know I feel like I
feel like the boring company is like
that for Musk like like like he he
opened his mouth and be like yeah just
big big you know dig big tunnels and
he's got enough credibility now where
some engineers went like yeah we could
build you know we could dig tunnels that
are seismically fine and like
you work for SpaceX okay like let's see
if you could build the dig a tunnel I
don't think that was like a business
plan you know right and and he just has
a lot of credibility you know at this
point I think that it's a certain extent
like a lot of people have a lot of ideas
they just don't dig down that that
rabbit hole and so you know I I do some
is like a hobby I do some where I kind
of have someone that I like within our
company and say well if you really
wanted to be independent and do
something cool like here's a project
like learn more about this and start
researching it you know we have you know
300 and some employees and the
restaurant side and about 50 on Talk
many of them are incredibly hardworking
and intelligent and when someone says
hey I want to learn how to be more
entrepreneurial I take one of my black
boxes up and say well let's see if
that's true take you six months of
independent work without any guidance
and you're gonna get tired of it really
fast but we're gonna come back to me and
say hey you know what like I can't
figure out the total value of the
truffle market in the United States I'm
like yeah no that's why I asked you
to do it haha
now would you give them an assignment
like this like you know what boss I
really want to be an entrepreneur like
congratulations I am now giving you a
project and a it's on your time and
you're not getting paid for it or do you
no no no I never never never take every
single intern that works at our
restaurants for a minute is paid gotcha
so even yes I thought so do you get paid
for the black box time oh yeah of course
yeah yeah I would never like I think one
of the things that I really dislike
actually our industry's like where they
say hey like you're you know you're in
college whatever you know be an intern
and then you know your parents say yeah
that's a great opportunity for you to
learn something and all that and it's
like well you're probably not if you're
not getting paid you're not being valued
frankly and for me I we pay everybody
like I don't nobody who's working here
if they're you know I I do expect that
you know salaried people are gonna work
more than just the time here and I think
that people who are passionately
curious will be given a problem like
that and we'll come up with interesting
solutions to finding out what the answer
may be and that's that's enough you know
mm-hmm so I once you add some sort of
commentary on the question that I asked
which is I think it's incredible that
you do pay them for that independent
research which is also acting as
entrepreneurial training / filtering for
them but I wouldn't have judged you
harshly at all if you said no that's on
their own time and the reason I say that
is that if you are going to be
investigating black boxes as an
entrepreneur there are going to be
periods of time where you are doing it
in the evenings you are doing it on the
weekends you are doing it without a
clear road to immediate cash flow right
so I wouldn't have judged you if you
said you know what I am paying them full
time for their normal job but if they
want to tackle one of these black boxes
that's considered extracurricular time
so I wouldn't have judged you harshly if
you had respondent in the in the
negative oh yeah I mean I guess I guess
you know to back up a little bit like
when there are people who I don't know
who do not work for a company and they
called me up and say hey I've got this
idea for XYZ or whatever and it's
intriguing enough I will I will pose
some more difficult questions but
they're not working for me you know what
I mean like right there's there's a guy
who brought me a food product that I you
know about a year ago and it was
interesting but not super compelling and
I said hey if you did these five things
it would be a lot more compelling for me
to be involved and to help with it and
all that and yesterday I got a box in
the mail and he had done not only the
five things I said but said hey when I
started doing those these seven other
things popped up here's where the
product is here's the people we signed
here's the airline we just signed to
carry the product and I would love to
have you still involved even though
we're so much farther down the road than
I thought it'd be or later that's super
cool I didn't pay that guy obviously but
there's a person who's truly
entrepreneurial right and did this on
his own time but if they're working here
if they work for the Alinea group if
they work for talk like for sure they're
you know you could take time during your
like doing your normal business that's a
project that we're working on and you
know we we also try not to have such
harshly defined roles not within the
restaurant like look if you're a server
if you're a captain if you're a line
cook you're probably not working on my
truffle project I mean realistically
yeah you know that's not that's but on
the business side
We certainly have people who who work in
roles as like a lawyer or an analyst or
something like that who want to get
involved with our publishing project or
who want to get involved with the
truffle project or whatever it may be
and you know I'm happy to pull them in
and try to include them and you know
like you said you you used a word as an
entrepreneurial filter I would say 95
percent of the time people filter
themselves out right yeah I agree with
that I mean they're gonna sell these
office Electress self-select out yeah
yeah are there any particular books and
resources that you've found useful on
hiring or managing god if you found one
let me know
no I hiring is so hard I think it's the
hardest of all things to do and I think
my style of interviewing people is
totally different than it was 20 years
ago we used the word self selecting just
a moment ago and it's exactly what I do
I kind of bring people in I let them
know what I'm about what the company is
about they've probably already been
interviewed by other people before they
they get to me and so at that point I
let them know like what are the upsides
and downsides of working here you know
and I kind of let them know what the
expectations are and I I tell them like
people self-select into a job and you
don't want to come here if you're gonna
fail because that would be terrible and
I don't want you to come here and fail
because that would be a waste of my time
and resources and would also feel awful
it's never good to let go of someone
feels terrible so let's see if you are
self selecting in what do you want to
know like I'll be completely transparent
about what's
what's bad what's good about working for
me personally the fact that maybe you'll
never see me again this is like a big
enough organization where you know there
are definitely people working here who I
don't know at all but people tend to
join organizations where they want to
work and so I I try to make that process
I try to make them be able to say no
easier than they can say yes what would
be some examples of how you do that you
know I kind of judged the person by what
their pain points are and so if someone
says like you know one things I like to
ask you know which kind of resonates
probably with you as I say here were
less fight books you read and I got to
tell you that's a really hard question
to answer because even if you're a
voracious reader it's really like you
remember like a book from two years ago
but you can't remember the one you read
two months ago
sometimes totally at least I can't you
know and so that is a great filter on
people because a couple things will
happen one the person who's a voracious
reader will go like oh my god I swear to
God I read like 20 books this year let's
see and they will really start going oh
I read one like three months ago that
was this and it was about that and you
could tell that they're intellectually
curious and and read a lot you'll also
get a person who goes look at and read a
book in 20 years but every night I go
home and I do woodworking and that's my
outlet like that's where I focus that's
my Zen moment and that's a valid answer
that question - you know like you don't
have to be a reader some people will
just lie through their teeth and they'll
answer what they think is the smart
answer to that question and I don't want
that person there read war and peace and
then I went to the problems of
philosophy and yes so so so there's that
and I ask that kind of question but then
like things like do you enjoy writing
like I like one of my like one of my
things is like if someone doesn't like
to write what do we when people ask what
I do for a living
say I'm a writer and they go like oh
you've written a couple books I go no no
I read about 400 emails a day and that
skill is hugely important right now if
someone doesn't like to write they're
not gonna want to work for me because
when when they send out an email and I
I'm CC done it and it isn't a well
thought out little thing the answer
coming back is like hey here's four ways
to improve this and at some point it'll
be like really you you did that same
mistake again like it comes off kind of
harsh an email you know and so if you're
the kind of person that doesn't take
feedback well or doesn't want to learn
like man I don't I'm lacking patience
for that at this point in my life and I
let them know that and some people like
look at you and just go like yeah dude I
don't want to work there like more than
I would think which is great yeah
simplifies matters yes and it's not it's
done with a smile you know I'm not like
trying to like terrorize people when
they come in an interview and then
there's some people I go like awesome
that's exactly what I want and you know
we've everything from like you know
double PhD engineers to people who've
never you know attended a university for
a minute and but they've they've self
selected into an organization that
people ask a lot of questions I love
that like I can be in room and come up
with an idea everyone there I'll just be
like well that's a great idea there's no
way we're gonna be able to do that in
the next six months because that's not
that's not in our that's not in our
capacity at our size right now I think a
question on a lot of people's minds and
a pain point for most people listening
will be email so you seem to be at least
confident in your treatment of email 400
is a lot of email do you have any
particular Commandments do's do nots
times you check things you check first
any types of systems or approaches that
allow you to maintain us a degree of
sanity with with the amount of email
that you must receive
is she you're gonna hate this answer I
am terrible at it it used to be not so
long ago that I personally replied to
absolutely every single email that came
in myself and I used to have an auto
sign that basically was like if I don't
reply to you within five minutes I'm
dead or asleep and it's the opposite of
everything that you stand for I know
that it's like Jason free so Jason
Fried's a friend I was listening to his
his podcast with you and I I don't get
it at all like I am NOT I would love
nothing more than you know to rework or
to not work you know you know work forty
weeks or to have six week projects and
all the stuff that he espouses he's a
friend he's an investor in one of my
businesses but man I don't that's not
how I function at all and I really think
that he misses cause-and-effect a little
bit like he has a very successful
company and that's the cause that allows
the effect which is the ability to
manage your time really well I live
really paranoid I'm more comfortable
that way and also I kind of feel like a
weird moral responsibility to reply to
the people who've taken their time out
of their day to write us a note you know
even if it's not like critical business
for me and one of the things I did for
about ten years that I loved doing when
we first start Alinea is that I would
have Google Alert set up and I would
find some blog you know that only like
some woman in her mother read you know
and I would reply personally like say
wow thank you for the great write-up
Alinea and they would be kind of mind
blown that I found it and you know all
that I treated email that way for a long
period of time unfortunately now I I
can't quite do that so I do have a bunch
of filters and whatnot but I didn't even
set them up my business partner bride
Fitzpatrick who used to be that at
Google Chicago and he's my
he runs the engineering team he's the
CTO of talk he kind of said like dude
you're you're slippin man like he how
you need to grate some filters and and
and get some stuff that's directly to
you so he went into my gmail accounts
and kind of kind of forced the issue for
me but so now I can't quite do that I do
wake up in the morning and look at sort
of our bazillion social media messages
and whatnot kind of pick a random one
and just answer it like I want to be
involved in knowing what our customers
are asking what they're doing what
they're saying what they're applying
anything that's a complaint actually
gets brought directly via email to a
complaint tracker that me and grant see
and so luckily there aren't that many of
those but anytime you serve five or six
thousand people a week you're gonna get
you know some something going wrong but
man I'm terrible at it honestly and I've
tried I will tell you a funny thing is
that when I go away in vacation I do try
to concoct a a pretty funny I basically
say like look I'm gonna be in a mountain
or on a boat or whatever and you're a
magnet reply what and so I would make
these elaborate stories up I almost it's
like a fun piece of art project as to
why I couldn't do it and so one year I
every year every time I went away I
basically said like I'm going to visit a
panda that I adopted back to Chicago and
it ended the year around Christmas time
when I went on break with a with a with
a picture of a baby panda and and a
really kind of mediocre Photoshop job of
me standing there and in the Chicago
Tribune called me up like three days
later going you know is it going to the
Lincoln Park Zoo like and I was like no
dear God it's not and the finally
there's no Panda
there's no reply to that and then the
following year I said like I like to
talk as you might be able to tell and so
everyone who knows me knows that like I
can just go on and on right and so I
said I was going to a combination of a
tantric sex retreat and silence retreat
for for eight days to explore my both
inner and outer self and this is your
out of office reply
that's my out of office reply and and
and anybody would get that right and so
I thought that was really funny and then
about two years later I bumped into some
guy who worked for a very big
corporation and they wanted to do some
work with with the only group and it was
like kind of a consulting project very
lucrative and he was looking at be
really funny you know and I said like
what's up and he said well you know I
really wish we had to work together but
you know then you went to that sex
retreat I just I just couldn't get it
past everybody and I was just like I was
looking up there like what are you
talking about
and then like four years earlier by
office reply and I told him like that it
was kind of a joke like the Panda and
and he did not find any humor in it and
I did I thought it was hilarious even
though we lost the business I thought it
was really funny so if you've ever get a
really unusual out of office reply for
me it's fiction probably I love that I
mean if you're serious all the time
you're never gonna get the actual series
weren't done you're gonna burn out
before that ever happens I also want to
underscore one thing and then I want to
ask you about a black box that you and
I've talked about quite a bit which is
publishing but the fact that you pick a
message to reply to even if it's one is
really important and I've noticed this
certainly with the audience that I have
listeners readers etc it is not
physically possible for me to reply to
everyone it would also be anathema to
everything that I'm espousing in many of
the books but it I do want to I do want
to demonstrate that I am listening and I
think that it goes a really long way
even if you do not personally reply to
people if you are able to prove that
you're paying attention and that seems
to resolve a lot or at least act as a
salv for people
out there who very seldom feel heard
which does not always necessitate a
response so I just wanted to point out
that it might seem like a drop in the
ocean but it actually has much more
further reaching implications when you
when you do it what what you were
describing yeah I I feel like it's
genuine first of all I'm always curious
like what what what are people writing
about to the restaurants what are they
writing about to me my LinkedIn profile
basically like I don't really read
LinkedIn at all I keep it I think it's
important to have it but I don't ever
read the messages on there but in my bio
it basically says if you can find my
email address I will I will incite this
I will reply to you and so that gets rid
of all of the marketing crap that comes
in but every now and then I get like you
know a subject line to the email address
that's on there that says basically like
you know hey via your LinkedIn bio and
I'll read that and reply it and it just
shows me that like hey there's an actual
human on the other line it's not just a
marketing thing and be like they really
really do have something that they want
to talk about and so you know it's like
little things like that or kind of
puzzle filters I guess that I call them
like where I just create like a little
bit of a little bit of a barrier and if
you if you're really into it and you
really want to talk to me you can pretty
much find me pretty easily I'm not that
hidden yeah and that the detail is
really important here the mini hurdle I
have a friend I'm not gonna mention by
name so I'll get deluged but he is a
very very successful author and
journalist and when he is hiring for a
different positions part-time or
full-time at the bottom of the job
description on a job site or wherever it
might be in in small print at the very
bottom it will say do not send a message
on this platform do not send an email
even though email addresses given
earlier call this number and leave a
voicemail answering the following things
and automatically he takes the pool of a
thousand people who are gonna do the
thought wrong thing and finds the ten
people are actually paying attention
yeah 100%
so publishing what is we didn't really
we didn't really talk much about it but
can you give a little bit just a bit of
background on the aviary and then some
of your related publishing
investigations which i think is is not i
think is not a miss in unappropriate
word if you could give people a little
bit of context yeah I mean I'm gonna
back up before the aviary just a little
bit and just go like you know for a chef
doing a cookbook it's something that
they dream about if they're serious chef
from the time they're 15 you know just
like if you're a basketball player you
want to make the NBA or you know if
you're a runner you know want to be in
the Olympics or whatever like to grant
to a bunch of chefs having their own
ideas in a physical beautiful cookbook
is kind of a holy grail for them it's
very sacred and what was interesting is
that just before grant was sick we
started getting a lot of publishing
offers and the natural inclination was
to go to what he knew which was artisan
press which published the French Laundry
book which is one of the best selling
high-end cookbooks ever and it's
certainly beautiful it was very
revolutionary at its time I think was
published in about 98 99 something like
that
and the typical publishing deal like
kind of came in to us which was great
that they were coming in and it was you
know 250 to 300 thousand dollars and
they would basically say well out of
that like you're gonna pay for the
designer and the photographer and you
need like a 30-day photoshoot and you
know here are the guidelines for how
many photos you want the book and you
know to keep costs down and this and
that and I kind of looked at all that
and all the offers came in within about
10% of each other which immediately you
know the hair on the back of my neck
like this fight you sense the spidey
sense that's telling me that something
back there is pricing this in a usual
way and then
and then I started going like oh this is
actually you like the music industry
thank you I knew people in in bands that
would get signed to a record label back
in the day and they would get a quarter
million dollar advance you know
that seems like a lot of money right and
then all of a sudden all your studio
time comes out of that and you don't
recoup another dime until you sold you
know X number of Records or CDs or in
this case books and then in the indie
contract it actually said and the
restaurant guarantees that they will buy
twenty five hundred bucks at half of
retail price and I was like whoa that's
you know you're looking at something
like eighty thousand dollars right there
that goes right back to them in essence
like and then I kind of went like well I
wonder what a book costs to print and I
mean I just called I asked them like
well how much is this book gonna cost to
print well I don't really know and so
what they would do is that they would
always have layers of people so that
they said well it's not what I do like I
am the person that does this the lawyers
give the contract the printer does the
printing like I there's always plan a
plausible deniability or plausible Allah
ignorance yes willful plausibly
ignorance yeah and and so I I do what I
start doing I'm like well let's just
Google that up and see what it print
cost to print a book or hey how many how
many copies of the French Laundry book
sold how many copies of fifty other
books that we wanted to emulate or that
we that we thought were well done sold
and man it's it's like asking for like
you know keys to the Vatican or
something when you call a publisher and
ask them that they I'm sure you know
this right you probably know now because
you've you've been so entrenched in the
industry like you know your numbers and
you might know the head of some of your
colleagues and friends right but if you
wanted to actually do a meaningful
comparison across the industry it's
almost impossible do it even though that
there's a company that does that then
you start trying to reverse-engineer it
and you go to the New York Times which
you can go the New York Times website
and just look at how is the New York
Times you know bestseller list
I'm created and on their own site they
say it's a compendium of known
publishers like publishing houses as
well as these like top 50 retailers you
know back in the day and it's a game
Abul system right like the way that that
the publisher publishers want to do it
is that they want to ship out all the
books at the same time because that's
how they're counted for the New York
Times bestseller list and stuff I should
also know it's not only game Abul but
it's also conversely highly subjective
within the New York Times so there
there's a lot of wiggle room in other
words as it is not like the Olympics
really okay clear gold silver bronze
video replay we know exactly how this
was was was it was tabulated yeah so the
more that we dug the more that we got
like Curie like more and more curious a
little bit angry actually and but Grant
was weirdly angry at me because he's
going like well dude like why do you
care
you know it's like I've been wanting
this since I was 15
and I was like well look if this is our
budget it's not gonna be the book you
want this I can be as good as you want
it to be because we're not gonna be able
to spend six months doing the
photography we're not going to be able
to get great pages when I can be able to
get a picture of every dish like if what
do people cook in a cookbook well they
tend to cook those pages where they see
a picture of the final dish because you
know what it looks delicious
you know it's supposed to look like you
got something to emulate at least right
and so when we did the specs for the
book I had one of the best publishers in
America say if you do that book there's
no way you sell more than five thousand
oh no way and no one's gonna publish it
and you can't use metric and you can't
use a gram scale and you can't have that
font and you can't have those pictures
in full bleed and it'll cost way too
much to print and so it took about a
month and a half before I got lucky and
I called a print broker who had actually
printed you know brokered the print job
of one of the famous books and I was
expecting that the book retailed for $60
it would cause
like fifteen to print 20 I didn't know
anything about it and when he told me it
was like two dollars and 23 cents per
book to print per 30,000 you know 30,000
copy run I went no way like that and he
went well it's probably less now it was
like too much right and and
instantaneously I went oh like
everything makes sense and when I would
call publishers and tell them this there
we go yeah but look like we did 40
different prints lat you know forty
different books last year only five of
them did well and I'm like that's your
problem man like I know what we're gonna
sell well I don't really give a if
you lost thirty five percent of the time
and it needed to spread your portfolio
risk
I'm the one you're spreading it on right
and so so we decided with the Alinea
book we put together like 20 pages and
Martin made this beautiful stainless
steel bracketing system and we shipped
it out to eight different publishers we
like two of which were art houses that
had never done a book and they all came
back and and same all the usual
criticism except for Aaron Weiner at ten
speed press yeah smart guy by the way
yeah and he basically said I'm gonna
make you an unusual offer no advance at
all and we can negotiate essentially
will just be the distributor and we'll
negotiate out like what that looks like
and we'll help you with the printing and
we'll help you with the editing which
we're both really good at and within ten
minutes we had struck a deal whereby any
of the books that we bought or sold for
ourselves for our restaurants we paid
actual printing costs not wholesale
actual printing cost anything that they
sold and distributed through their
channels they would get about 27% of the
sale price which means that we got 73%
of that these are like state secrets
right like like nobody tells this stuff
and so for years I was walking around
with this knowledge where if we sold a
hundred thousand books say I
that would be the equivalent selling
like 500,000 books on any other deal and
we got to control the quality of it and
we won both the dreams Beard Award for
Best cooking from a professional point
of view best cookbook of the year and we
won
I say we Martin and Laura Kastner won
the Communication Arts Award where if
you're a designer that's like their
annual is like that's like getting the
Oscar right yeah similarly for people
who don't know it I mean the James Beard
Awards are also very much like the
Oscars yeah so so we felt like really
vindicated on that the book still sells
this is eight years later we still sell
seven eight thousand copies a year and
when we did the aviary which is our bar
that's a non bar that we talked about
earlier you know we started getting all
the same offers again and this time it
was really easy to go like uh just kind
of like go like oh that's cute like you
know and so I should add that we did I
wrote a book of grant I wrote his memoir
together that we didn't use a
ghostwriter we wrote it ourselves to
life on the line and for that one we did
a traditional book deal but after our
agent kind of got it halfway I got on
our plane and flew out there and then
brokered the deal myself and I got a
giant multiple of the highest bid by
doing essentially a reverse Dutch
auction starting at a really high price
and working my way down word can you
explain for people just briefly yeah
yeah so basically like here I'll do this
like let's say so I think one of the
great problems like to solve one the
black boxes is the agency problem let's
say you want to sell your house you put
it on the market and the agent is gonna
get I don't know four to five percent of
the sale price that's a lot for
something that's like your most biggest
investment your life but they kind of
say like they control the information
they control the MLS all that will they
if they're the sellers agent get the
highest price for you and the answer is
almost certainly not because they let's
say your house is gonna sell for five
hundred thousand dollars they can get
or percent of that that's $20,000 if
they get $490,000 it's almost no
difference to them right 400 bucks
difference but if they lose the deal
over that last 10,000 it's it's a lot so
they want a price a home so that it
sells quickly so they can keep their
deal flow going and they don't really
care about maximizing their last dollar
whereas for you that last dollar is
actually like ninety six hundred dollars
it's a lot more money so what I do
whenever I've sold real estate is that I
figure out what the intrinsic values of
the house like what's the bare minimum
that I'd be willing to sell it for and I
price it just slightly higher than that
and I tell all the agents in the whole
town I will pay you 50% of everything
over ten percent higher than that and
they all say oh that's against the real
estate ethics code or I would never do
that deal because it would subvert all
my other deals or whatever and then what
happens is two days later you get like a
dozen phone calls and they've priced it
like forty percent higher and they're
and like the it sells in two days
yeah because now they're actually
working for you right well it's
similarly I went into that that
publishing negotiation and I was kind of
like by the way the agent it's probably
look up a bull she's great like great
person I don't think she even knows that
that's what was happening do you know
what I mean like I don't even think she
she just knows that like hey she was
brought up in this in this industry for
this company and that's the way it works
and she would for sure dispute
everything I just said she would say I
always try to get the highest price but
I went in and I just went like like am I
gonna spend my time doing this for X so
I need four times that and she was like
there's no way you'll ever get that
you've never written a book before I
said well we did the Alinea book that's
a cookbook doesn't count these are words
so so I went to the publishers that I'll
bid on it and I just got them all on a
conference call and just started a
really high price and every couple
seconds I went down ten thousand dollars
and then one of them blinked and bought
it what was the that's a great way as
great method of price discovery like if
you think about it most auctions even
like you go to a charity event remember
they start low and they try to get
interest going high it's often the case
that if they start really really high
and start going down people start going
like oh my god someone's gonna say
something like I would pay that someone
else must as well they could be off by a
factor of 30% and they'll never even
know it because there's only one bid
that ever happened mm-hmm so no one
knows how off they are now on that phone
call we're like hey guys would love to
get you on the phone and then publisher
right away well yeah so did I guess my
question is did they know that they were
signing up for a like Mexican standoff
you could it might be fun but I didn't
do that I wouldn't talked ain't I
created enticement I sold on my ability
to actually do it it was a bit like
doing the no phones with the software
like I was like well if I get a really
big contract off to figure out how to
write a book and that'll be a lot of
pressure and so so I did that and and
and and I wrote it and I turned it in on
time which apparently no one does very
very rare yeah yeah because like Davis
do they went what's this I'm like that's
the manuscript yeah oh that's cute well
it's kind of like showing up at the
restaurant on time as a diner and then
being seated at the point of time it's
just this like open open lie I do
actually yeah I believe that yeah I do
turn my books in on time and we could
get into that I do I do not turn them in
at the expected length yeah I do tend to
so what happened with the aviary is that
we like we basically couldn't figure out
how to do another book because the
Alinea book was such a
project and Martin was on to other
things and we didn't want to do it
traditionally and I didn't know anyone
who could do what we wanted to do and
then there was this guy Alan hamburger
and boy if you get nothing else from
from this whole talk and you've made it
this far go see go Google Ellen and
Alinea Alan is a procedural effects
artist he worked at wettest studios and
all the Hobbit movies doing like hair
and water and things like that so he
writes the physics that then makes the
makes the magic right and then he worked
at Pixar and while he was at Pixar and
his wife Sarah worked at Industrial
Light Magic as the graphics designer he
was given by Sarah a copy of the Alinea
book to go full circle and became just
fascinated with it wasn't out of coke
did not a cook and did the Julie and
Julia thing he spent five years not only
cooking his way through the entire book
but also would do things like well I
don't know where to get this plate and
I've always wanted to learn how to fire
porcelain Allen for people wondering is
a llen there are also videos of Allen &
Alinea yeah and he's an autodidact like
this guy learns and learns and learns
and is the kind of person that goes to
the black box and goes I'm gonna learn
how to forge knives and I'm gonna learn
how to fire porcelain and by the way I'm
gonna cook everything in there and I'm
gonna take pictures of it and make a
book documenting that and when he asked
if he could use like we had kind of a
little email relationship and he came up
to Alinea wants to ask grant some
questions about how to make something
because it wasn't working and when grant
kind of threw up his arms go by the book
might be wrong
like Allen's worldview was shattered it
was like well you know we did have some
errata in there like I mean we
documented hundreds of recipes it could
be wrong and at that point down like his
mentality changed it's in the video and
and we got to know him and I got to know
him and when he sent me the book it
wasn't what I was expecting I was
expecting like a homegrown book
and what I got was you know a 400-page
beautifully beautifully illustrated
beautifully written book about a
person's journey of learning and it was
called the Alinea project and I had no
no idea that he had done anything like
this and so suddenly I thought to myself
immediately and it's in the intro to the
aviary book I texted him and said holy
you're crazy and I have ideas and
after waiting for like four or five
years to do a book on the aviary I
immediately was like this is the guy to
do the book now I need to lure him out
of Pixar which is about the best place
to work in the world and then I found
out his wife worked at Industrial Light
magic and she did all the graphic design
and I was like this is perfect
you guys need to quit your jobs and move
to Chicago and they flew out we had some
conversations about what they might look
like it was very much a partnership they
would have equity in the book we would
have creative freedom to do it exactly
the way we wanted we knew more about the
printing and the bidding and all that so
I wasn't worried about the economics of
it anymore
I was worried about trying to make
something really awesome and right as
they were about to say yes they would
they found out they were gonna have a
baby so they called me up one day and
said oh my god
like I was like oh they got cold feet oh
no and they said you know we're pregnant
we're gonna have a baby and I said okay
well we're gonna wait a year because
there's no way in the world I'm letting
you move out out of your comfort zone
and have a child and have that change of
life and they thought I was like punting
on them just because like in a
discriminatory way I said nope we're not
gonna do this with anyone else we'll
wait as long as it takes
and about a year and a half later they
moved to Chicago and we spent the last
year and a half to set up a studio of
our own it spent the last year over half
doing this book did a Kickstarter to
just essentially raise awareness for it
we raised almost a half a million
dollars in the Kickstarter but you sold
about another $300,000 a book since then
I comes out in October you go the Alenia
book calm and the
part of that website is in if you look
at he Alinea book oh sorry
Thievery book comp era right
so yeah the aviary book calm but if you
the coolest part of that is other than
of course your ability to buy said book
is alan kept the blog on there called
our progress and in it he details every
single aspect of what it takes to make a
book like this right down to line
screens and compositing photos of you
know like one of the things that every
single book publisher told me is that
you can't sell a cocktail book for more
than thirty dollars there's no market
for it and you don't need pictures
because it's just liquid in a glass and
i think we blew that out of the water
with what the book looks like i think
that because certain things like fire
are really hard to photograph there's a
great picture in there of this one
cocktail where we respray some anise and
we light it on fire and it creates an
aroma into the bowl that it's served in
it's called loaded to the gunwales
it's a butabi Arak cocktail and like
that took a composite of eighteen
different photographs and so he breaks
down the photography techniques and also
the New York Times bestseller list and I
showed him like how you know google
target marketing works and Facebook Ads
work and all that and all of a sudden he
went holy I had no idea you could
do this so we are going completely
without a distributor a publisher at
this time and I think we're gonna set a
man I don't know like I'm either
completely delusional it wouldn't
surprise me if we sold a half million of
these yeah and his next two or three
years and it's yeah it's not a nut of
9.95 book either which it shouldn't be
right i mean this is it's it's $85 we've
invested close to a million dollars all
the way in around it and it looks like
it I think I hope yeah from what I've
seen it looks like it would cost more
than that yeah what we did you know we
did it all ourselves too you know it's
really like a five person project it's
it's deep enough that if a professional
sit there gonna learn a lot but I'd say
about 3540 percent of it can be done at
home because unlike the Alinea book
where hey you gotta go out by duck like
you know and your local grocer you might
not have this kind of decorative if you
need some flirty kind of rum or you know
you know a certain kind of tequila or
whatever you just go to your local
liquor store it's exactly the same thing
that we use you know that product is
universal I read somewhere that's that I
don't think is taking us too far afield
I read somewhere that you consider
yourself a tequila guy or at least in
part a tequila guy do you have any
favorite tequila's or concoctions well
there's so I just I'm gonna do a little
video promo for for the book that we
just filmed last week where essentially
I work with Eric Jeff is one of our
bartenders in the office which is our a
little speakeasy below the aviary which
is amazing if people have the
opportunity they should check it out
it's basically grant just said hey
everything upstairs people are gonna
think it's Fellini of smoke and mirrors
we need to prove we can make a real
cocktail so one of the foundational
cocktails for me is is a daiquiri it's I
say three ingredients and a million ways
to it up you know it's it's just
lime sugar and rum that's all it is and
and yet like most bars you go into will
make a terrible daiquiri or they'll
blend it or blah blah blah right but a
great daiquiri is really really
transformative so did a video on that
and then I always make a half mezcal
margarita that's my favorite drink all
I'm doing is I'm taking some Reposado
and a little bit of mezcal and equal
weights along with some you know a Grand
Marnier or Cointreau equivalent and lime
and simple syrup that's it that's all
there is to it man I love the simple
stuff like that and then we have a whole
section in the book on old whiskey's
dusty bottles old gins like there's a
growing movement to kind of rediscover
some of the distilleries in America that
were really really really great that
don't exist anymore
that were more artisanal at the time you
can still find those bottles around it's
a little bit easier than like you know
someone like wine collecting or
something like that
and man it's like an endlessly
fascinating thing I don't consider
myself a cocktail person ten years ago I
really loved wine
I felt like from a health perspective it
was better as well but just like
anything else if you have a
well-constructed cocktail and something
of high quality it's an additive thing
like you can have it in a meal and it
can make the meal better you know
whereas like you know a vodka tonics
just boozing and it's just getting drunk
that's not what we're trying to do here
we're trying to make things that are
it's really a culinary approach to
cocktails and man it's endlessly
fascinating just like anything else in
in this world and the the the I would
also save just contrasting say someone
who wants to recreate something from
Alinea which you certainly could do I
mean I'll improve that with something
from the aviary there is also a
tremendous amount of theater and
presentation dynamism that you can
create with cocktails that does not have
to be super expensive or super
complicated that I mean certainly you
guys are able to go as complex as you
want to go which is stunning and I've
spent time at the aviary but you can
easily make some ice with pastry ODEs
bitters and it or something like that
and then as the ice melts in the
cocktail it's going to change the flavor
and it's gonna look really cool too I'm
doing some of these things at home is
not hard I did a dinner party once where
it was like you know cocktail party
probably had 40 people at my house and
each room in my house had all of the
ingredients for the cocktail and then a
little instructions on how to make it
themselves so I took away the need for a
bartender because they're terrible
anyway anyone that you'd bring in and
you know that you know caterer or
something like that
and the other cool thing is that people
got really into it they went like Oh
like and I know how to make an
old-fashioned now I know how to make in
Manhattan you know I the one that I
discovered that party was a frisco sour
had like Benedictine whiskey and lemon
you know it was really delicious so it
it can be it can be more than just like
a strong cocktail it can be really
delicate and interesting mm-hmm and
people can
learn all about this at the aviary
book.com centers right yeah
well Nick I have to rapid-fire questions
that are unrelated and then I think
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
bring this neat and tidy round one
podcast two to it to a close but we've
talked about books and everybody should
not only check out the aviary book but
also if they have a chance go to the
aviary it is it is tremendous and you
can also get some delicious bites and
food at least last time I was there
staying at the aviary so it is a bit of
a I hesitate to call it a workaround but
you guys have some very very popular
establishments if you want to sample the
food this is also a great way to do it
and the drinks are just incredible so
it's it's a real sort of destination
that makes a trip to Chicago worth it in
and of itself so I would recommend not
only checking out the book but also
checking out a lot of what you guys are
up to aside from that books you have
gifted the most other people outside of
those that you've made yourself what are
the books that you have gifted the most
to other people yeah I named one of them
ready fooled by randomness almost
everyone in my office is forced to read
you know and I've definitely given that
away
boy that's a tricky one because I just
like I said I can't remember I can't
remember books very well but that's
certainly probably number one on a
business side of things and then the on
the other side I tend to give away but I
would call vintage art books so it's not
a book people can buy I'm sorry to say
but occasionally I'll be like you use
bookstore and I'll find some of these
great old art books and I buy a few of
them and then when I what I want to
thank someone for something I send him
that peregrinations of an epicurean
something like that yeah I mean at the
end of the day like I I bought like what
I want to give someone something I try
to make it something that you
and I really want to make it a great
gift I try to get it something that you
can't buy right and so I bought an old
typewriter and I write when I write a
thank-you note I type it up on the old
typewriter and it is the most
confounding thing to people haha because
they look at it and they go how did you
do that I'm like on a 1922 typewriter
it's like a personal artisanal thing but
I know that that's not what you're
getting at
no like I can't really think of I can't
really think of like the number one I'm
sure once we we we in this I'll
immediately think of it and if I do else
I'll send it to you so you can link to
it I think the answer the answer is more
interesting with the typewriter so I I
think what I'm getting at was whatever
you just offered so that's perfect and
if you come up with anything else we can
put in the show notes this is this next
one can be tough at times for folks but
the Billboard questions so
metaphorically speaking non-commercial
no advertising but if you could get a a
word a quote a sentence a question up on
a billboard to transmit something to
millions or billions of people does
anything come to mind that you might put
on that billboard I don't know why this
came to mind but the but the word would
be pause hmm I say I have no idea why
that came to mind but I think in in
talking through this whole thing I you
know it's you kept asking me like why
are you digging this black box sort of
or it'd be like curiosity like and I
think those are two I'm thinking of
those in the same way
I'm not saying pause like stop I'm
saying think right and so I think you
know the the hallmark of the people that
I like as friends the best is what we
try to instill in our kids you know and
and the reason I like my wife so much
malla is that intellectual curiosity is
everything and so I don't know how do
you get that on a billboard I think
pause or you know be curious or
something like that I know it's cliche
but I think that's the thing the thread
that ties everything together yeah you
do pause a lot you
no on a macro level you seem to be
moving at hyperspeed a lot of the time
there are a lot of pauses built into
that speed if that makes sense
from what I've noticed I mean your
assignment you you are simultaneously
one of the craziest I know and
least craziest I know if that
makes and where can people find you I
know you have of course the the linear
group com you have explore TOCOM the
aviary book.com which is the sort of the
most timely for people to check out
right now if people want to say hello or
follow you on social where the best best
best places best handles for that yep
Instagram which is an cojones Ko Ko nes
and twitter is nick cojones and i ck and
it's all google right like so happy on
that if you could figure out my email
address I'll probably answer given the
given the reach of your podcast perhaps
I will be inundated it might take a
while yeah that might be a hug of death
situation but we all had TBD good
problem down Nick this is a blast thank
you so much for taking the time I really
really think she's in and many more
conversations to be had this I think
another trip to Chicago may be in order
so say I hope we see you here sigh and
how I need to get back and to everybody
listening we've made mention of the show
notes links to everything we've
discussed which you will be able to find
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast as
with this episode and certainly every
other episode and until next time thank
you so much for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday event provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday's a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour workweek com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
Charlotte's Web which makes a CBD oil a
hemp extract that has become one of my
go-to tools now I have never really
talked about CBD oil and cannabis has
never really been the plant for me and
only talking about hemp but nonetheless
after several nights of inexplicable
insomnia this is about Europe I just
could not get to sleep saved my life and
after other fixes failed so melatonin
and California Poppy extract that it
ended up an elite athlete introduced me
to this non psychoactive extract and bam
problem solved I had some of the best
sleep that I've had in months now I
don't use sleep aids on a daily basis
but this has become part of my toolkit
and I hope to be exploring other
applications soon CBD oil products have
exploded in popularity in the health and
wellness of Fitness worlds and
Charlotte's Web is one of the top
players that offers a broad spectrum
hemp extract with CBD in the form of
oils capsules and topical products
Charlotte's Web products will not get
you high so that maybe that his good
news may have bad news to you but it
does have some powerful benefits and the
applications and it works with your
body's existing endocannabinoids system
and no meaning from within like endo vs
exoskeleton princess so endocannabinoid
system works with your body some of the
most common uses are for relief from
everyday stressors help in supporting
restful sleep which is what I most often
use it for to bring about a sense of
calm and focus a lot of my friends use
for that CBD is also known for becoming
known for helping athletes to recover
from exercise-induced inflammation
Charlotte's Web him extract has
naturally occurring terpenes flavonoids
and other valuable hemp compounds that
work synergistically to heighten
positive effects sometimes refer to as
the entourage effect which you guys can
look up making it more complete than a
single compound CBD alternatives or at
least that is what I've been told I do
not know much about CBD alternatives nor
single compound in any case check it out
this stuff has really worked for me so
jump over to CW hemp dot-com or slash
Tim CW is in Charlotte's Web CW Kemp
dot-com for Tosh Tim to take a quick
quiz which will determine the best
product for your particular Ames
lifestyle etc and they ship to all 50
states Charles Webb are offering
listeners of this podcast 10% off of
their purchase while there are some
exclusions I personally use the extra
strength CBD oils for the extra
strengthen capsules and you can see what
might be a fit for you on that page and
there is a 30-day risk free guarantee so
why not try them to get 10% off of your
purchase at CW hem comm forward slash
Tim and disclaimer these statements have
not been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration this product is not
intended to diagnose treat cure or
prevent any disease enjoy this episode
is brought to you by 99designs 99designs
is the global creative platform makes it
easy for designers and clients to work
from logos to apps business cards
packaging to books you name it 99designs
is the go-to design resource for any
budget right now my listeners that see
you guys can get $50 off a logo and
brand identity package from 99 designs
plus a free upgrade that lets you
promote your project all in the platform
which is an additional $99 value by
checking out 99 designs dot-com forward
slash 10 50 that's TI m50 99 science
compote slash Tim 50 as many of you know
I've used 99 designs for many many years
now I've used them for book covers
including mock-ups for the 4-hour body
which went on to become a number one New
York Times best seller illustrations for
the multi-volume The Tao of Seneca ebook
series basically and other graphic
design projects and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers and illustrators and you can
check out all sorts of stuff like Tao of
Seneca to get an idea they're they're
really mind-boggling most recently I
used 99 designs to update the
illustrations and layout of my 5 morning
rituals ebook this is a PDF that I offer
as an incentive to get people to sign up
for my newsletter the illustrations
inside are gorgeous and I loved working
with the designer who ended up selecting
for the project you can take a look at
that this is a real world example of the
type of thing that I used 99 designs for
at 99 designs com4 / Tim 50 99 designs
designer search tool connects you
directly with one designer based on
design category or industry
specialization style skill level
availability and more you just check off
the boxes that you need to satisfy the
criteria you want and it will bring up
the best matches or even start a contest
you invite the entire community to take
a shot at your project then you pick
your favorite so to get $50 off your
first logo and grant identity package as
well as additional promotion on the
platform with the free upgrade please
visit 99designs dot-com forward slash
Tim 50 that's 99designs comm forward
slash 1050 and click on the link on the
landing page check it out 99designs
dot-com forward slash attend the 50
you